WE'LL CALL THE MEETING TO ORDER.
THIS IS THE BUDGET COMMITTEE SUB
FIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY -- WHEN
WELCOME YOU ALL HERE TODAY AND --
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL.
WEBER HERE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
GREAT WE HAVE A QUORUM WHICH
MEANS WE CAN START AT THE TOP OF
THE AGENDA WITH A VOTE ONLY
ITEMS.
THAT ARE HERE WELL BEGIN WITH
HER.
EIGHT EIGHT ONE TWENTY FOLD
ITEMS ISSUE ONE AND THEN ISSUE --
TOO SEN MOVED IN SECOND ON ISSUE
ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS
INCREASED POLICE OFFICER
TRAINING.
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY THAT'S APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR ISSUE ITEM
NUMBER.
ONE THAT IS A FOUR OH IT PASSES
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS -- ISSUE NUMBER TWO
WHICH MAY REVISION AMENDMENT TO
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS OUR
MOTION IS BEEN MOVED.
THE SECOND THAT THE APPROVED THE
ADOPTION OF THE AS A BUDGET IN
AND ADOPT PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ROLL CALL.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT OF FOR VOTE WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
AUDITING AND OVERSIGHT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY AND SECOND
ROLL CALL WEBER I'M JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FOR VOTE AND
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THAT BRINGS ISSUE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS A PENAL CODE
REVIEW APPROVED THIS BUDGET IT
ADOPTED A PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE [inaudible]
SMOKE NOTE.
A SECOND.
WEBER ROLL CALLED UP I JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
GIVE THAT IS A TWO TO VOTE WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THAT ITEM IS STILL IS
HELD OVER OPEN.
OF HIS OWN CALL ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE WHICH IS A JUVENILE COURT
PROBATION STATISTICAL SYSTEM
INTO THE DOCK THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS OUR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OBERNOLTE.
IS THAT IS OUT ON A FOR VOTE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX WHICH IS A
PEACE OFFICER RADIO REPLACEMENT
APPROVED AS BUDGET IT IS OUR
MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
SECOND THE SECOND ROW CALL WEBER
I JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OBERNOLTE.
THIS OUT ONLY -- FOR VOTE WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS -- ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS A CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
SECOND APPROVED AS A BUDGET IT'S
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OBERNOLTE.
IT'S NOT ONLY -- FOR VOTE WILL
ALSO HOLD IT OPEN ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT CALIFORNIA INTERNET
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND NET
NEUTRALITY ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IS REMOVED.
YES -- IS THE MOTION -- THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION THAT THE
DOJ MAY ONLY SPEND THE PROPOSED
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION TO
ENFORCE SB TWENTY TWO IF ALL
CORPORATIONS.
PREVENTING ITS IMPLEMENTATION
ENFORCEMENT HAVE EXPIRED RIGHT
AND I THAT WAS GOING TO READ
THAT IT APPROVED THE PROPOSAL
AND ADOPT BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
SPECIFIED THAT FUNDING CAN ONLY
BE SPENT.
IF ALL COURT PROVISIONS
PREVENTING IMPLEMENTATION OR
ENFORCEMENT HAVE EXPIRED OR BEEN
REMOVED THAT IS A MOTION SIR
THERE'S A BIT MOVED IN SECOND
BROKAW.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
FIVE MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FOR VOTE WITH
THE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER NINE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVAL
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ONE POSITION IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY ON GOING
AND ADOPT PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
IT IS NOT ONLY -- FOR VOTING
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER TEN WHICH IS A
CANNABIS CONVICTION RE
SENTENCING THIS IS TO RECOMMEND
APPROVED AS BUDGET IT THEIR
MOTION.
BEEN MOVED [inaudible]
A SECOND.
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY VOTING [inaudible]
MELENDEZ STONE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY THAT'S OF TWO ONE VOTE ONE
NOT VOTING -- WOULD THAT MOTION
IS BEING HELD OVER.
IT'S SO ON CALL AND FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. TO VOTE THAT
BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
WHICH IS VERY IS PROPOSES TO
IMPLEMENT LEGISLATION AND
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVED HIS
BUDGET THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ITEMS LISTED. SEVEN SMOLDERED
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
IT'S OUT ON A FOR VOTER WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS -- ISSUED NUMBER TWELVE
WHICH IS NEW AND EXPANDED CRIMES
THIS IS A RECOMMENDATION TO
REJECT THE PROPOSAL IS THEIR
MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY -- FOR VOTE TO
REJECT THE PROPOSAL.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
DISPOSITION WORKLOAD.
A RECOMMENDATION AS TO REJECT
THE PROPOSAL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY THAT IS -- PASSES ON A FOUR
OH VOTE TO REJECT THE PROPOSAL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SEXUAL
PREDATORY APPREHENSION TEAMS AS
WE APPROVED HIS BUDGET IT.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY THAT IS OUT ONLY -- FOR
VOTE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR AT
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN WHICH DEALS WITH
JUDICIAL BRANCH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVED HIS
BUDGET.
BEEN MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I'M JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OBERNOLTE.
IT'S OUT ON THE FLOOR -- VOTE
AND WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBER THAT WAS APPROVED
THIS BUDGET.
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN MAY
REVISION TRIAL COURT EMPLOYEES
BENEFIT ADJUSTMENT AND TRIAL
COURT TRUST FUND SHORTFALL
ADJUSTMENT.
IS RECOMMENDATION APPROVED THIS
BUDGET IT THE MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED IN SECOND ROLL
CALL WEBER.
JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE THAT IS NOT ONLY --
FOR VOTE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS -- ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN WAS CORRECT
SOME TRAINING FACILITY SOLD AT
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION CELL
DOOR REACHED RETROFIT
RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED.
OKAY WELL CALL WEBER I'M JONES
SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY -- FOR VOTED
THAT PROPOSAL WAS REJECTED ISSUE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AND WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
A ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN DAHLE
VOCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS FREE BY
A NEW BALL OF FACILITY THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OBERNOLTE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FOR VOTE TO
REJECT THE PROPOSAL AND WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN WHICH
IS INCREASE IN INMATE LITERACY
LITERACY THE POLL THIS BUDGET IS
OUR MOTION. SEVEN MOLD A SECOND.
WHAT?
OKAY ROCCA WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY VOTING [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY THERE IS A TWO ONE VOTE AT
THIS TIME -- WE WILL BE HELD
OPEN FOR OF THE ABSENT MEMBER
AND THAT IS ON CALL.
THAT BRINGS US TO ISSUE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY VARIOUS HEALTH
CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS THAT IS APPROVED AS
BUDGET IT THEIR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL WEBER I DON'T SAWYER
LACKEY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FOR VOTER WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBER.
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE
WHICH IS CALIFORNIANS TO FOR MEN
AIR COOLING FACILITY APPROVED AS
BUDGET IT ROLL CALL I MEAN SKEWS
ME IS MOTIONS SO MODE.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OBERNOLTE.
HEY THAT GIVES US FOR ALL AND
THAT'S OUT WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS APPROVED THIS
BUDGET.
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO
WHICH IS A STE SPRING BCP HEALTH
CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROJECT INCREASE LEASE REVENUE
APPROPRIATION A RECOMMENDATION
APPROVED HIS BUDGET AND ADOPT.
A PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS THERE MOTION IT'S
BEEN MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I'M JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OBERNOLTE.
THAT IS NOT ONLY FOR ALL VOTE WE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE
WHICH IS A SPRING BCP STAFF
COMPLAINT PROCESSES
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
IS MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I'M JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE THAT IS OUT ON A FOR
VOTE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS -- THE ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS A
SPRING BCP SAN QUENTIN STATE
PRISON THE WALL FACILITY --
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVED AS
BUDGET IT ZERO IT'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED ROLL CALL WEBER.
JONES SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ
STONE.
OBERNOLTE THAT IS OUT ON THE
FLOOR -- VOTES IT WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
BRINGS US TO ISSUE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE WHICH IS A PAROLE
HEARING COMMISSIONERS.
A T. B. L. OF APPROVED THE
PROPOSAL AND ADOPT A PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
IT'S BEEN MODE.
SECOND THE ROLL CALL WEBER NINE
JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FOR OLD VOTE
AND WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX
WHICH IS A VERY IS MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS APPROVED AS
BUDGET THERE ARE THREE ITEMS.
THIS IS A SIX ITEMS LISTED I
GUESS.
WILL STOP THE DAY THAT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS SIX ITEMS OKAY
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL.
WEBER TRY JONES SAWYER LACKEY
MELENDEZ STONE OBERNOLTE.
AND THAT IS OUT ON A FOR VOTE
AND WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THAT BRINGS US TO
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER -- TWENTY
SEVEN SPRING FOR OF THE SPRING
LETTERS EXTENSION OF LIQUIDATION
OF PROPOSITION ONE BE APPROVED
THIS BUDGET IS THERE A MOTION.
REMOVE THE SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER HI JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OBERNOLTE.
THAT IS NOT ONLY -- FOR VOTES
WITHOUT HOLD IT OPEN WE WILL --
KEEP YOUR ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBER VOTE NUMBER ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT VARIOUS MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS -- THEY
INCLUDE A A NUMBER FOR PROPOSES
IS APPROVED AS BUDGET IT.
IS THEIR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OBERNOLTE IT'S
NOT ONLY -- FOR VOTE WILL HOLD
IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY NINE THIS IS
DEALS WITH THE JUDGES RETIREMENT
MAY REVISION PROPOSAL APPROVED
THIS BUDGET IT.
IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OBERNOLTE.
THAT'S OUT ON A FOR VOTED WILL
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBER -- I
THINK THAT IN ALL OF OUR VOTE
ONLY I DON'T.
THIS. TWENTY TWENTY NINE YES
OKAY.
WAS IT EASIER SO [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY WE'VE HAD A A REQUEST WE
HAVE SOME INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
TO CATCH A FLIGHT -- AND SO
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR THEIR ISSUE
FIRST AND VERY BRIEFLY OF THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES I
THINK THEY ARE HERE AND HAVE A
FLIGHT TO CATCH SO THEY WANT.
TO MAKE THEIR PRESENTATIONS WERE
ASKING EVERYONE WHO'S MAKING
PRESENTATIONS TO BE SOMEWHAT
BRIEF -- CONCERNING THOSE
PRESENTATIONS HOME [inaudible]
THIS IS
.
OF WE WANT TO RE OPEN ISSUE ITEM
YOU CAN REMAIN WHERE YOU ARE
ITEM VOTE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AND IT'S CONCERNING --
INCREASED POLICE OFFICER
TRAINING THERE'S SOME CONCERN
ABOUT IT AND OUR COLLEAGUES WANT
TO OF DO THE CALL AGAIN AND DOES
THE WILL CALL THE ROLL AGAIN --
WE HAD A MOTION AND A SECOND SO
LET'S MOVE FORWARD WEBER HI
JONES SAWYER LACKEY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ STONE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY SO WE HAVE IT'S A TWO TWO
OF TWO VOTES.
I TWO ABSTENTIONS AND WE HAVE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN THAT
THAT -- IS ON CALL AND WE HAVE A
IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WELL AS OTHERS WHO WANT TO WE
WANT TO CHANGE THE BILL ONCE
THEY SEE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
SO WE'LL DO THAT OKAY THANK YOU.
NO PROBLEM ALL RIGHT THAT BRINGS
US TO ITEM SEVEN EIGHT HUNDRED
NEEDS THE ITEMS TO BE HEARD
TODAY.
YES.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARKET
ARE DUE TO DIRECTOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES GREAT TO BE WITH YOU
THIS AFTERNOON -- WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS THAT -- WE HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU TODAY FOR CONSIDERATION --
LET ME PREFACE BY JUST BY --
SORT OF FRAMING THAT YOU KNOW AS
AS THE OBVIOUS THAT YOU ALL KNOW
THAT -- HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE BEEN EXPERIENCE -- YOU KNOW
FOR SEVERAL DEVASTATING
DISASTERS OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS -- AND AND IN FACT -- IF
YOU THINK ABOUT -- SINCE IT IT
LITERALLY TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN WE'VE HAD WELL OVER A
HUNDRED STATE OF EMERGENCIES AND
THE DISASTERS WE FACE HAVE
RESULTED IN.
FOURTEEN PRESIDENTIAL DISASTER
DECLARATION THIS UNPRECEDENTED
NUMBER OF PRESIDENTIAL DISASTER
DECLARATIONS -- PRESIDENTIAL
DISASTER DECLARATIONS WOULD
START OFF AT AT A MINIMUM OF
FIFTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
DESTRUCTION -- AND THEN THAT WAS
THE ALL THE WRAPAROUND IMPACTS
TO TO OUR COMMUNITIES -- THAT IS
ALL RESULTED IN A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WORKLOAD IN EFFORT ON
THE PART OF STATE AGENCIES AND
AND THE OFFICER MERGING SERVICES.
IN FACT IN JUST SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN ALONE -- WE HAD THE THE
LOSS OF OVER.
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND STRUCTURES
THAT'S HOMES AND BUSINESSES
DESTROYED -- AND OF COURSE AS WE
UNFORTUNATELY NO THREE HUNDRED
FATALITIES AND IN THE CAMPFIRE
ALONE LAST YEAR WERE EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND STRUCTURES THAT WERE
DESTROYED -- THIS IS BEEN IN
ADDITION WHILE FIRE IS REALLY
THE FOCUS WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT LAST FEW WEEKS BUT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED IN THE LAST --
SEVERAL YEARS EARTHQUAKES FLOODS --
FAILURES OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE --
THIS BILL WAY -- TERRORIST
ATTACK ACTIVE SHOOTERS EXCEPT
FOR A THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE'VE BEEN VERY
VERY BUSY AND I'LL COME BACK TO
THAT IN.
A FEW MINUTES BECAUSE IT SPEAKS
TO ONE OF THE THE PER POLLS WILL
MAKING I WANT TO START OFF BY.
TALKING A LITTLE ABOUT WHILE FAR
THOUGH AND SPECIFICALLY -- IN
THE EFFORT -- ACROSS ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES TO PREPARE
FOR THIS YEAR'S WILDFIRE SEASON
THAT'S UPON US NOW -- WE HAVE
BEEN ENGAGED VERY VERY
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES AND THEY HAVE
SIGNAL TO US THEIR INTENT TO
INCREASE THE USE.
OF WHAT THEY CALL -- PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF THIS IS A
PREEMPTIVE -- SHOT OFF OF POWER
IN ADVANCE OF POTENTIAL -- FIRE
START SO -- GIVEN A SERIES OF
CONDITIONS WEATHER HUMIDITY WIND
EXCEPT FOR A THEY WILL THEY WILL
MAKE AN EVALUATION AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT THEY ARE GOING TO SHUT
OFF THEIR POWER AND OF COURSE --
SHUTTING OFF POWER IN THE SHORT
RUN FOR A FEW HOURS -- IS --
MANAGEABLE SUSTAINABLE SHUTTING
OFF POWER OVER THE COURSE OF
SEVERAL DAYS -- UP TO TEN OR
FIFTEEN DAYS IS A MUCH DIFFERENT
STORY AND AND AND WE WE ARE
WORKING WITH THEM AND HAVING
THEM WORK WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- TO
PREPARE FOR THE POTENTIAL
CASCADING IMPACTS OF THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO OF OF THEM --
SHUTTING DOWN THE POWER
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OVER PROPER
LONG PERIOD OF TIME -- AS A PART
OF THAT IS OUR EFFORT TO BUILD --
RESILIENCY AND RELIABILITY.
IN THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
RESPOND -- EFFECTIVELY TO THESE
CASCADING IMPACTS -- AND THAT IS
ONE OF THE WE HAS BEEN MADE HERE
THERE IS A REQUEST -- FOR ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION TO
TO BUILD RESILIENCY IN THE
STATE'S CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE --
IN IN RESPONSE TO THESE --
POWERSHOT OFFICE -- AS WELL AS
TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN PREPARING -- FOR
THE THE SHUT OFF AND AND REALLY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN THE TIER.
TWO AND TIER -- THREE SERVE US --
SEVERE AND EXTREME -- FIRES AS I
HAVE A MAP BEHIND ME -- THAT YOU
CAN SEE THE DIFFERENCE --
BETWEEN THE TIER TWO WHICH IS
ELEVATED WHICH IS THE YELLOW AND
TIER THREE WHICH IS THE EXTREME.
AND OVERLAID IN THE EXTREME AND
THE ELEVATED OR A NUMBER OF
STATE -- CRITICAL FACILITIES
THAT ARE USED -- IN RESPONSE
OPERATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN SUPPORT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
SO THE FIRST PART OF THIS IS HIS
HARDENING -- THOSE GROUP DOES A
CRITICAL FACILITIES -- BY --
PROCURING ANY UP AND PUTTING IN
PLACE -- MERGES YOU BACK UP
POWER REALLY THAT IS THE FOCUS
OF OF THIS -- PIECE OF THE
HARDENING OF THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT IS CAL FIRE STATIONS -- YES --
REGIONAL OPERATIONS CENTERS
EMERGENCY OPERATION CENTERS --
THAT IS CDC OUR THAT IS OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION --
TIER ONE FOOD DISTRIBUTION
WAREHOUSES IN THE FIRES OWNS
THESE ARE CRITICAL FACILITIES
DID YOU CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE
EMERGENCY BACKUP POWER -- AND
AND THIS WOULD BE -- ALLOCATING --
ROUGHLY SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS --
TO SUPPORT -- THE PROCUREMENT
AND AND AND I HOOK UP OF THESE --
OF THESE GENERATORS AND OTHER
KINDS OF POWERS WAS NOT A SORRY
ALL GENERATOR SOME COULD BE
BATTERY BACKUP AND OTHER KINDS
OF OF MODERN -- CAPABILITIES THE
OTHER PIECE OF THIS IS --
SUPPORT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
THE FORM OF GRANTS -- THE THESE
WOULD BE GRANTS TO THE FIFTY
EIGHT ARE WHAT WE CALL
OPERATIONAL AREAS OR COUNTIES --
TO BE ABLE TO UPDATE TO DO
SEVERAL THINGS ONE IS TO UPDATE
THEIR OWN THEIR EMERGENCY PLAN
TO INCLUDE AN ANNEX FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF -- THIS IS
A NEW CONCEPT -- BUT I'LL USE IT
BEEN WORKING WITH THE COUNTIES
AND WE KNOW THAT THE THAT THE
EMERGENCY -- YOU KNOW THE
SPECIFICS REGARDING PSP **** --
ARE NEW AND WE WANT TO GET THAT
INCORPORATED THEIR EMERGENCY
PLANS.
IT ALSO WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
CONVENE REGIONAL STAKEHOLDER.
MEETINGS AND AND AND AND
DISCUSSIONS SUMMITS AND AND HOLD
TRAINING AND EXERCISES TO RE IN.
THOSE PLANNING ASSUMPTION SO
THAT'S BRINGING YOUR FIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC HEALTH -- AND
THE COMMUNITY TOGETHER IN SOME
TOWN HALL MEETINGS WITH REGARDS --
TO THE LOCAL -- GOVERNMENT AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS A HUGE
COMPONENT OF OF OF GROUP -- THAT --
REALLY ARE IMPACTED THE MOST --
BY ONE OF THESE POWERSHOT OFFICE --
AND THEN OF COURSE THAT WOULD BE
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A PROGRAM
TO SUPPORT WHEN THE I USE --
THESE ARE I USED LED THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS THESE
ARE CENTERS THAT THEY WILL SET
UP FOR POWER -- AND INFORMATION
FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY BE AND
IT IS KNOWN THAT MAY HAVE THEIR
POWER TURNED OFF -- HAVING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- BUILD THAT INTO
THEIR RESPONSE CAPABILITIES.
SO -- ON THE FIRST -- OUR
REQUEST IS THIS ISSUE OF OF
THESE THIS -- ENHANCED --
RESILIENCY CAPABILITY -- FOR
STATE FACILITIES AND FOR
SUPPORTING LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
PREPARATION OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF -- ANY QUESTION
ABOUT THAT BEFORE YOU GO TO
CHANGE COMING FROM LA -- FROM
FINANCE.
NO LL NINE CHRISTY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
IN GENERAL WE THINK THIS CONCEPT
MAKES SENSE CERTAINLY POWER SHUT
OFF CAN BE DEVASTATING TO
COMMUNITIES IN CAN PRESENT LINE
PUBLIC LIFE AND AND SAFETY
CONCERNS -- HOWEVER AT THIS TIME
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A LACK OF
CLARITY ON SOME OF THE DETAILS
OF THE PROPOSAL AND EXACTLY HOW
THEY CAME UP WITH THIS PROPOSED
SPENDING AMOUNT.
OF AND HOW TO COORDINATE WITH
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES --
IF AT ALL AND THAT AND SO WE WE
THINK THAT IF THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTERESTED IN PURSUING THIS
CONCEPT -- THE TO CONSIDER WE
SUGGEST TO CONSIDER MODIFYING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- WE
PROVIDE A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER AS IT DOES SO ON THAT
COULD BE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THAT FURTHER SPECIFIES HOW THESE
FUNDS COULD BE USED ON IT COULD
BE.
PROVIDING FUNDING ONLY FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY SO THIS THIS
PROPOSED FUNDING WOULD WOULD BE
FOR THREE YEARS IT COULD BE A
LIMITING ITS ONE YEAR AND HAVING
SOME REPORTING.
I'M IT COULD ALSO BE ON MAKING
CONTINGENT ON PROVIDE THAT
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDING A MORE
DETAILED PLAN SO THEY'RE READY
DIFFERENT OPTIONS THEY'RE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE -- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER I'M
JUST IMPROVE A LITTLE BIT OF THE
OVERSIGHT AND TO GET SOME MORE
DETAILS ON THIS PROPOSAL WHICH
WHICH IS THAT CERTAINLY VERY
IMPORTANT BUT AT WE THINK LACKS
IN DETAIL AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS YES MISTER
OPEN OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO I SHARE
THE LA THOSE CONCERNS THE I
THINK WE'RE ALL UNITED IN OUR IN
OUR INTENTION -- TO TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE HARDENED AGAINST THESE
POWER SHUT OFF EVENTS BUT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR BACKUP
GENERATORS AS A LOT OF MONEY.
AND I THINK THAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
SOME MORE SPECIFICITY IN TERMS
OF HOW EXACTLY YOU PROPOSED TO
SPEND THAT MONEY -- BEFORE THE
OTHER VOTES TAKEN ON THIS IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE.
SURE I MEAN I I MAY JUST ADD
THAT IT WE DID A SURVEY OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE A
RESPONSE RESPONSIBILITY OR HAVE
CRITICAL FACILITIES LIKE CDC ARE
LIKE STATE HOSPITALS LIKE --
DEPARTMENT OF BAD AS AS WELL AS
THE RESPONSE ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
CAL FIRE AND AND WE ASSN C. H.
P. -- YOU MAY BE SURPRISED TO
KNOW THAT THEIR THEIR ART.
EMERGENCY BACKUP -- POWER AT
MOST OF THESE FACILITIES FOR
LOTS OF DIFFERENT REASONS -- AND
SO THE SURVEY IS NOT ASKING
EVERY STATE AGENCY.
IT'S NOT ASKING EVERY EVERY
STATE AGENCY THAT EVEN IS IN
THAT TIER ONE OR TWO IT'S REALLY
THOSE.
THOSE DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
THAT HAVE -- A CRITICAL ROLE --
IN SUPPORTING THE COMMUNITY IN
THE CASCADING IMPACTS BUT I MEAN
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE WHERE YOU'RE
AT AND AND HAPPY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AS WE
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE THIS -- IF
YOU COULD JUST PROVIDE THAT
BREAK DOWN THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED ABOUT HOW YOU ARRIVED
AT THE SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
FIGURE YOU KNOW WHO WHO WOULD
GET THE BACKUP GENERATORS NEED
TO PROJECTED COST OF THEM.
THINK THAT BE VERY HELPFUL SHARE
THAT BE HAPPY THAT YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND THE
AGENCY THAT YOU REPRESENT ENTRY
IN FAVOR OF THE PROPOSAL.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CARE MORTENSEN
ON THE UP THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION -- WE WOULD ALSO -- I
AGREE WITH LA OWES COMMENTS --
AND SUPPORT SOME BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT ADDED A LITTLE BIT
MORE SPECIFICALLY ABOUT OR
SPECIFICS -- TO THE DETAILS AS
THERE'S A AS DIRECTOR YOUR DUE
TO MENTION THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
NEED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH THE P.
YOU SEE ON THE RULE MAKING
PROCESS.
AND COMMUNICATION OUT REACH TO
RESIDENTS WITH IN JURISDICTIONS
THAT WILL HAVE A PEAK POWER SHUT
DOWN IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN
ADDITION TO PLANNING -- AND ALSO
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
REDUNDANCY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IS
A NECESSARY AS WELL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY ANY UP THING FOR MEMBERS
THIS ITEMS BEING HELD OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
WHICH IS THE MAYBE VISION
DISASTER PLANNING PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE PROPOSAL GREAT
THANK YOU SO THIS -- ONE OF BOB
SORT OF BOB CONNECTS BACK WITH
MY OPENING STATEMENT ABOUT THE
THE AMOUNT OF DISASTERS WE SEEN
IN IN CONTINUE -- TO EXPERIENCE --
AND AND AND THIS PROPOSAL IS IS
IS YOU A LITTLE BIT UNIQUE WE WE
WE WE WORKED WITH -- WITH
ADMINISTRATION -- TO DEVELOP --
A CAPABILITY THAT REALLY SPEAKS
TO AN ISSUE OF SUSTAINMENT AND
AND ABILITY TO DEAL WITH THESE
ON ON SLOT OF OF NON -- AND
BEING A MEMBER DISEASE A
DISASTER SO THIS ONE IS -- A A
PROGRAM THAT WOULD FIND. SEVEN
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND AND AND
ROUGHLY EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND IN FEDERAL TRUST FUND --
FOR NINETY FOUR POSITIONS -- AT
YES BEGINNING IN -- NINETEEN
TWENTY TO SUPPORT ALL OF THIS
ACTIVITY IN.
RESPONSE PLANNING PREPAREDNESS --
EXCEPT TRUCK AND WE BROKEN THIS
DOWN -- INTO -- THREE DIFFERENT.
BUCKETS ARE PROBLEMS IF YOU WHAT
AND REALLY IT IS -- IN ESSENCE A
IN INNOVATIVE WAYS NOT JUST A
BIG DUMP OF A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT IT IN THE
IN A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS OF
BUILDING CAPACITY THE FIRST ONE
IS THAT WE HAVE.
CURRENTLY HAVE A NUMBER OF
LIMITED TERM.
POSITIONS THAT WE'VE HAD TO US
STAFF UP -- FOR THESE
EMERGENCIES AND OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST -- SEVERAL
EMERGENCIES -- AND AND IT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE WERE ASKING THAT
THESE LIMITED TERMS BE --
CONVERTED TO PERMANENT POSITIONS
THE SUPPORT THE ONGOING WORKLOAD
AND AND THE VARIOUS AREAS OF THE
DEPARTMENT -- AND AND AND JUST --
JUST THE BACKLOG AND REMEMBER I
I MENTION TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
BUT WE ACTUALLY HAVE OPEN
DISASTERS -- THAT -- GO BACK ALL
WAIT ABOUT-- TWO THOUSAND THREE
BECAUSE A LOT OF YOUR
INFRASTRUCTURE DISASTERS AND SO
A LOT OF THIS GETS PUT OFTEN PUT
OFF WITH REGARDS TO THE NEW
DISASTERS YOU ONLY HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF RESOURCES TO
GO AROUND -- AND SO THE FIRST
PART IS IS -- LIMITED TERM
CONVERSION DEPARTMENT AT ROUGHLY
THIRTY SIX POSITIONS THE SECOND
PART OF THAT IS A NEW POSITION%
REQUEST -- ROUGHLY FORTY
POSITIONS -- THESE ARE AREAS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE --
IDENTIFIED A POSITION THAT
IDENTIFIED CRITICAL POSITIONS IN
GAPS THAT WE HAVE -- EXPERIENCE
IN THE CURRENT -- THIS SERIES OF
DISASTERS -- THAT WE KNOW -- WE
NEED -- ONE KEY THING TO
REMEMBER IS THAT.
AT A WE ASK WHICH IS UNIQUE IS
THAT WE ARE PLANNING A PREPARING
IN PEACETIME -- AND AND AND
TRAINING AND EXERCISES WHEN WE
RESPOND RESPONDING WITH WITH ALL
THE OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES.
MANY THIS PUBLIC AGENCIES
AGENCIES AFTER THE RESPONSES
OVER GO BACK TO THEIR STEADY
STATE A WE ASK CONTINUES WITH
THE RECOVERY OPERATIONS. TO BE
ABLE TO RECOVER AND WILL FAR
BEFORE THOSE RECOVERY OPERATIONS
ARE OVER WE'RE BACK INTO
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SO IT'S
ALMOST A SELF LOOKING ICE CAN GO
WE CAN.
CONTINUALLY HAVE -- THE NEED --
TO RESPOND AND WHEN WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A A RESOURCE PROBLEM DOING
THAT AND THAT THIS A SECOND
PRONG -- THIS PART OF THIS FIRST --
BUCK AND AT IN OTHER WORDS WOULD
TO INCLUDE -- FORTY NEW
POSITIONS TO HELP ADDRESS THAT --
THE SECOND.
PRONG OR BUCKET IS -- WHAT WE
CALL MISSION TASKING -- FUND
APPROPRIATION THIS IS A NEW
PROGRAM -- MANY TIMES WE ARE
MISSION TASKING OTHER STATE
AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO STEP UP
AND RESPONDED AND EMERGENCY OR
PARTICIPATE IN THE RECOVERY --
THESE THESE AGENCIES ARE NOT
GENERALLY FUNDED FOR THAT.
AND IT'S A CONTINUAL CHALLENGE --
TO BE ABLE TO GET RESOURCES AND
AGENCIES COMMITTED OVER A PERIOD
OF TIME -- WITHOUT HAVING TO GO
BACK FOR DEFICIENCIES OR OTHER
KINDS OF ASPECTS IN THIS IN
ESSENCE IS A PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
INCLUDE TWENTY MILLION. TO GOING
TO A OF A FIND -- THAT WOULD
FIND STATE AGENCIES THAT HAVE
BEEN MISSION TASK BY -- YES --
TO IMMEDIATELY GIVEN THAT FRONT
LOADED TO FIND DEAN -- SO
THERE'S NOT A QUESTION OF HOW
THEY GONNA PAY AND PUT THEIR
BUDGETS IN A CRISIS SITUATION --
END UP PART OF ADDING INCLUDES --
UP SOME POSITIONS PROPOSITIONS
TO ADMINISTER THAT FINE AND AND
TRACK THIS IS CRITICAL BECAUSE
THIS ALSO -- TRACKS THE AMOUNT
OF RECOVERY DOLLARS THAT WE GET
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
FOR DISASTER RESPONSE AND IN
ESSENCE THIS AT THIS INITIATIVE
REALLY WOULD PAY FOR ITSELF BY
HAVING VERY -- CLEAR --
AFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT WAYS OF
BEING ABLE -- TO RAPIDLY GET OUR
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT BACK WE
WANT TO MAXIMIZE WAS FEDERAL
REIMBURSE BACK PARTICULARLY IN
CURRENT.
POLITICAL CLIMATE IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE ALL OF
OUR RESOURCES APPROPRIATELY --
IN LINE -- TO MAXIMIZE OUR
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS.
AND THEN THE LAST PIECE OF THAT --
IS A CONTINUITY AND SEARCH
CAPACITY THIS IS REALLY -- AN
INTERESTING -- IDEA TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD IN ESSENCE A STATEWIDE
DISASTER RESERVE CORPS.
THIS IS REALLY AN INVESTMENT --
ON THE FRONT END -- TO BUILD --
INDIVIDUALS RETIREES -- FROM
LOCAL STATE OR FEDERAL OR
PRIVATE SECTOR THEY WANT TO
BECOME A RESERVIST WITH US THAT
HAVE A TECHNICAL EXPERTISE THAT
WE COULD BRING TO THE TABLE AND
USED DURING AN EMERGENCY -- AND
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO BUILD
THAT RESERVE CORPS AND PROVIDE
SOME TRAINING FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND WE WOULD ONLY
CALL THEM WHEN NEEDED.
AND WE WOULD EMPLOY THEM TO
SUPPORT -- I WAS IN A MAJOR
DISASTER AND IT WOULD REALLY BY
DOWN THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT WE
HAVE TO GO OUT AND BRING IN.
PRE VET CONTRACTS AND TRY TO
TRACKDOWN AND BUILD UP
RESOURCES SO -- THIS IS REALLY A
A PROGRAM MODELED AFTER THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- AND FEMALE
WHERE THEY'VE GOT A DISASTER
RESERVE -- PROGRAM AND IT'S BEEN
A VERY SUCCESSFUL -- IN COST
EFFECTIVE IN BEING ABLE -- TO
MANAGE THAT PROGRAM SO THAT IS
IN ESSENCE THE SECOND -- REQUEST
THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU
SOUNDS GOOD OKAY ANY COMMENTS
FROM L. FROM FINANCE.
MANAGER STEVE EVENTS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST WANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS
PART OF A LARGER ADMINISTRATION
STATEWIDE PACKAGE THE THAT FIRST
PRONG THAT THE DIRECTOR SPOKE
ABOUT WITH THE CAN BASS LINE.
INCREASES IN RESOURCES AFFECTS
EIGHT DEPARTMENTS IT WAS KIND OF
REALLY THOUGHT ABOUT AND
TARGETED WAYS TO TRY AND LIFT
THE THE RAISE THE BOAT IF YOU
WILL.
ACROSS THE STATE IN TERMS OF OUR
PREPAREDNESS TO RESPOND THESE
EMERGENCIES AND SO IT'S KIND OF
REAL INTERCALL AND HOW THESE ALL
WORK TOGETHER [inaudible]
HELLO.
AS WE HAVE A FEW COMMENTS AS WAS
NOTED THERE ARE THREE SEPARATE
COMPONENTS OF THIS -- REQUEST
ALL GO THROUGH THEM --
SEQUENTIALLY THE FIRST BEING
THAT -- YES STAFF RESOURCES --
WE WOULD NOTE THAT IN MANY CASES
OTHER QUEST SO CONCLUDES
BASICALLY BROAD -- AUGMENTATIONS
ACROSS A VARIETY OF P. PARTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT THAT INCLUDES
THINGS LIKE YOUR CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER AS WELL AS
THEIR PLANNING ACTIVITIES AS
WELL AS THEIR RESPONSE TRACKING
AT HR AND YEAH IT'S JUST IT'S
VERY BROAD ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT.
AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT IN MANY
CASES THEIR QUEST PROVIDES A
BROAD DESCRIPTION OF THE GENERAL
TYPE OF ACTIVITY THAT SECTION
DOES OR MAYBE EVEN THOSE
POSITIONS -- BUT IT'S OFTEN
UNCLEAR SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE
CURRENT LEVEL OF SAID STAFFING
IS FOR THOSE ACTIVITIES WHAT THE
SPECIFIC GAPS ARE AS WELL AS WHY
THE SPECIFIC NUMBER OF PERSONNEL
ARE REQUESTED AND SO.
AND WE THINK THAT THERE'S
THERE'S A LACK OF OF SORT OF
THAT DETAILED INFORMATION THAT
WE WOULD WE WOULD IDEALLY LIKE
TO SEE.
ACCORDINGLY WE'RE RECOMMENDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SEEK THIS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION -- IF THE
DEPARTMENT ISN'T ABLE TO PROVIDE
IT -- IN TIME FOR THIS BUDGET WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER REJECTING ON THEIR
QUEST IN WHOLE OR IN PART OR
COULD ALSO AS POTENTIALLY
APPROVED A NEW POSITIONS ON A
LIMITED TERM BASIS AND THAT
WOULD NOT HAVE THEM COME BACK
AND PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL AT THAT POINT -- WITH
REGARD TO THE SECOND PIECE THE
MISSION TASKING THAT THAT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR FUND AS WELL AS
THAT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE TWELVE POSITIONS
TO ADMINISTER THAT -- WE KNOW
THAT THE CONCEPT OF ESTABLISHING
SUCH A FIND -- IS CERTAINLY A
PROMISING ONE HOWEVER AGAIN --
IT'S INCLUDE US EXACTLY HOW THAT --
BUT THE BASIS IS FOR THAT
FUNDING AMOUNT AND AND IN TERMS
OF THE THE STOP LEVEL OF STAFF
RESOURCES IT'S UNCLEAR TO US --
WHETHER THAT'S THE RIGHT LEVEL --
PARTICULARLY WOULD NOTE THAT --
THAT FINDINGS REQUESTED FOR
THOSE POSITIONS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS -- WELL THE FIND WOULD
ONLY BE SPENT OVER THE NEXT
ROUGHLY THREE YEARS AND SO ON
THERE'S ALSO SOME QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER ON GOING FUNDING IS
APPROPRIATE AND CASE.
ACCORDINGLY RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SEEK ADDITIONAL
DETAILS ON ON THE STAFF LEVEL
AND IT CERTAINLY IF THE
LEGISLATURE THINKS THAT THE
GENERAL CONCEPT OF THIS FIND
MAKES SENSE WE RECOMMEND -- THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER CONSIDER --
IMPLEMENTING AS A PILOT PROJECT --
SO IT COULD FOR EXAMPLE PROVIDE
THE FUNDING ON A FOR THE
POSITIONS ON A LIMITED TERM
BASIS -- EITHER IN WHOLE OR IN
PART -- ESTABLISH PERHAPS YOU
COULD ESTABLISH OUT REQUIRE THAT
THEY THAT THEY HAVE THE FUND IN
PLACE FOR YOU HAVE SAY A YEAR
AND THEN COMMON REPORT BACK ON
ON KIND OF WHAT THEY'VE DONE
WITH IT AND AND HOW IT'S WORKING.
WE THINK THAT'LL IMPROVE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND ENSURE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE UNDERSTAND
SIR BUT IT'S FUNDING AND WHAT
THE OUTCOMES ARE -- AND THEN
WITH REGARD TO THE THIRD PIECE
THAT WAS THAT I SAID ROUGHLY
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND AND SIX
POSITIONS FOR THAT.
A DISASTER RESERVE CORPS --
REALLY THESE FOLKS AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT ARE GONNA BE DOING
THE RESEARCH TO IDENTIFY HOW
THIS WOULD BE DONE SO THEY
THEY'LL BE KIND OF TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THIS NEW PROGRAM
WOULD BE RYAN -- AGAIN WE THINK
THAT THE IDEA OF THIS HAS HAD
QUITE A BIT OF PROMISE BUT
THERE'S ALSO A LACK OF DETAIL
HERE.
ACCORDINGLY -- SIMILAR TO THAT
THE PREVIOUS COMPONENTS BE
SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SEEK THESE ADDITIONAL DETAILS --
IF THAT ISN'T AVAILABLE -- BUT
AGAIN IF THE LEGISLATURE THINK
THAT THIS IS A CONCEPT WORTH
PURSUING WE RECOMMEND --
APPROVING THE POSITIONS -- AND
FUNDING ON A TWO YEAR LIMIT TERM
BASIS AGAIN WITH SOME REPORTING.
SO ADDICTED LEGISLATURE HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW THIS -- THIS NEW
IDEA OF A RESERVE CORPS IS
WORKING AND WHETHER WANTS TO
CONTINUE INVESTING IN IT OKAY
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS YES I COULD JUST
MAKE ONE CLARIFICATION ON THAT
SECOND PRONG THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE MISSION TASKING.
IS ONE TIME SO IF WE WANTED TO
DO A SIMILAR THING IN FUTURE
YEARS WE WOULD BE BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASK FOR THAT IT'S
IT'S A ONE TIME REQUEST.
THANK YOU ARE A PART BROAD
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
IT'S NEW AND WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT KIND RIGHT LEVEL
IS AND IT'LL VERY BY.
WHAT DISASTERS WE HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR YEAR?
OKAY THANK YOU THREE COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS THE QUESTION.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
THANK YOU THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD
OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT BRINGS US BACK TO ITEM --
NUMBER ONE I BELIEVE -- WITH THE
TRADITIONAL.
RENTS ARE BELIEVED.
BRINGS TO THE SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGE.
ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE HOW ARE YOU GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN.
SEE A DOCTOR WEBER -- GOOD
AFTERNOON -- DOCTOR WEBER AND
THAT AND NUMBER SOME MY NAME IS
LOT COMPUTER WHICH ON THE BUDGET
DIRECTOR FOR THE DISH A BRANCH.
AND I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT --
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
REGARDING JUDGESHIPS.
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES A
THIRTY POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND
THIRTY SIX AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALLOCATE --
TWENTY FIVE ADDITIONAL
JUDGESHIPS AS AUTHORIZED BY
CHAPTER SEVEN TWENTY TWO OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN THE REQUEST
ESTIMATED TOTAL COST PER
JUDGESHIP IS SIMILAR NEED TO THE
AMOUNT THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET.
WHICH REFLECTS FUNDING FOR
JUDICIAL COMPENSATION OPERATING
EXPENSES EQUIPMENT INTERPRETERS
AND COURTS STAFFING -- THIS
WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
JUDGESHIPS AND COUNTIES THAT
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING THE MOST
CRITICAL NEEDS FOR NEW JUDICIAL
RESOURCES AND ADDRESS -- MANY
ASPECTS OF ACCESS TO THE TO THE
COURTS IN WAS A WELCOME
INVESTMENT -- AT THIS YEAR AND I
HAVE A DANCE EVER HEARD HERE
FROM ASSEMBLY IN A COURT TO TALK
ABOUT THE BENEFITS TO THE COURTS
AND ALSO HAVE LEAH ROSE GOOD ONE
HERE WHO CAN.
BE FULLY DESCRIBE THE METHOD BY
WHICH WE DETERMINE OUR JUDICIAL
NEEDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
NANCY EVER HEARD COURT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FROM SAMBAR TO DINO
SUPERIOR COURT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HEARING
FROM US THIS AFTERNOON OUR COURT
HAS A CURRENT NEED OF THIRTY
EIGHT JUDGES TO ACCOMPLISH THE
WORK OF THE COMMUNITY.
OUR EXISTING SEVENTY THREE
JUDGES AND FIFTEEN COMMISSIONERS
DO THE WORK OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX JUDGES THAT'S ONE AND
A HALF JUDGES -- FOR THE AMOUNT
OF CALENDARS THAT WE HAVE.
JUDGES IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY ALSO
SHARE THIS BURDEN AS TO FIFTEEN
OTHER COUNTIES.
GIVEN THE HOUSING BOOM IN
SOUTHWEST RIVERSIDE AND THE HIGH
DESERT AND WEST END OF SAN
BERNADINE OUT THE SITUATION WILL
ONLY WORSEN.
ON MONDAY BY WAY OF EXAMPLE I
WAS VISITING THE VICTORVILLE
COURTHOUSE AND HAD LUNCH WITH
THE SUPERVISING JUDGE SHE HAD
JUST FINISHED A HUNDRED MATTER
MISTER MEANER ARRAIGNMENT
CALENDAR.
AND AFTER LUNCH HAD A HUNDRED
MATTERS MORE TO GO -- MISTER
MUNIS USUALLY HAVE DRUG PROBLEMS
ALCOHOL PROBLEMS MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS.
ON THIS CALENDAR THE AVERAGE
JUST THIRTY SECONDS A IN ORDER
FOR THE DEFENDANT TO UNDERSTAND --
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE
COURTROOM AND BE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS?
ON TUESDAY I PULL THE CALENDAR
FOR FAMILY COURT OVER THIRTEEN
FAMILY COURT ROOMS.
WE HAD TWENTY THREE CUSTODY
VISITATION.
AND SUPPORT ORDERS OR HEARINGS
GOING ON IN EACH OF THE COURT
ROOMS SO IN ORDER TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR WHERE A CHILD IS
GOING TO BE -- FOR VISITATION
AND FOR SUPPORT.
THAT'S ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES PER
FAMILY TO MAKE DECISIONS ON
CRISIS.
IN OUR JUVENILE DEPENDENCY COURT
ROOMS WE HAVE FOUR JUDGES COURT
WIDE.
OUR NEW FILINGS ARE EIGHT
HUNDRED FILINGS PER YEAR PER
JUDGE ANY CARRY AN ACTIVE
CASELOAD OF OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
FAMILIES.
THE NEED FOR MORE JUDGES HAS
BEEN IDENTIFIED SINCE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS WHEN WE BEGAN
ANALYZING THE WORKLOAD.
AND LEGISLATION HAS FIRST BEEN
INTRODUCED IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
AND SUBSEQUENTLY SINCE THEN.
OUR COMMUNITY IS IN NEED IS IN
DESPERATE NEED OF JUDGES
ESPECIALLY IN THE REMOTE AREAS
OF OUR COUNTY WHERE CAN TAKE
THREE AND A HALF HOURS BY CAR
RIGHT TO GET TO A COURT ROOM.
OR IS A TWELVE HOUR DAY BY
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
SO THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING OUR
PROPOSALS AND MAY I ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
LEAH ROSE GOOD WHEN I AM THE
MANAGER OF THE OFFICE OF COURT
RESEARCH AT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
AND IT IS OF MY OFFICE THAT BUT
DOES THE ASSESSMENT OF JUDICIAL
NEEDS.
I JUST AS A REMINDER THE
JUDICIAL NEEDS ASSESSMENT IS A
BIENNIAL REPORT THAT ARE A
JUDICIAL BRANCH PRODUCES THAT
SHOWS THE NEED FOR JUDGESHIPS
BASED ON WORKLOAD.
THE JUDGE MODEL HAS THREE BASIC
COMPONENTS ONE IS THAT IT IS
BASED ON A THREE YEAR AVERAGE OF
FILENE'S AND WE MEASURE FILINGS
IN DIFFERENT CASE TYPES.
OF FAMILY LAW CIVIL AND CRIMINAL.
A IT IS ALSO BASED ON WORKLOAD
STANDARDS ALSO CALLED CASE
WEIGHTS THAT MEASURE THE FULL
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT CASES OF
VARIOUS STATE TYPES TAKE.
FROM FILING THROUGH DISPOSITION
AND INCLUDING ANY POST
DISPOSITION ACTIVITY.
AND FINALLY THE THIRD COMPONENT
OF THE MODEL IS A PRIORITIZATION
METHOD.
THAT DETERMINES IN WHAT ORDER
JUDGES SHOULD BE ALLOCATED.
IN IT REFLECTS COUNCIL
PRIORITIES -- OVER THE LAST
DECADE AS WELL AS IT IS CODIFIED
IN GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION.
SIX NINE SIX ONE FOUR AT THE
COUNCIL PRIORITIES. FOR JUDICIAL
ALLOCATION ARE BASICALLY TO
CONSIDER COURTS WITH THE
GREATEST WORKLOAD NEED.
BUT TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO COURTS
FOR THE GREATEST NUMBER OF USERS.
I TO KEEP IN MIND THE
AVAILABILITY OF COURT FACILITIES
FOR PLACING NEW JUDGES.
AND TO ENSURE THAT SMALL COURTS
ARE ELIGIBLE A TO QUALIFY FOR
NEW JUDGESHIPS.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE WITH
OUR ALLOCATION MODEL.
IS ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
COURTS OF VERY DIFFERENT SIZES
SO IN SAN BERNADINO FOR EXAMPLE
A LARGE JURISDICTION -- THEY
NEED THIRTY EIGHT JUDGESHIPS A
SMALL CORD. FOR EXAMPLE LIKE
LASSEN OR SHASTA MAY NEED ONLY
ONE SHOULD SHIP BUT THAT ONE
JUDGESHIP REPRESENTS 30% OF THE
WORKLOAD NEED IN THAT COURT.
SO WE USE A METHOD THAT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO HOW SEATS ARE
APPORTIONED IN CONGRESS IT'S
BASED ON THE EQUAL PROPORTIONS
METHOD.
AND IT BASICALLY ACCOUNTS.
FOR BUT I'D COURTS NUMERIC NEED
THEIR PERCENTAGE NEED FOR
JUDGESHIP AND ALSO THE RELATIVE
NEED FOR THAT FIRST JUDGESHIP.
COMPARED TO ALL OTHER JUDGESHIPS
NEEDED.
BUT THE BRANCHES RIGHT IN THE
MIDST OF UPDATING THE CASE
WEIGHTS THAT ARE USED TO MEASURE.
BY HOW MUCH TIME IS NEEDED FOR
CASES OF VARIOUS TYPES LAST
UPDATE OF OUR MODEL WAS.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AND THERE
ARE ALL SORTS OF NEW TYPES OF
WORKLOAD AND CHANGES IN WORKLOAD
AS WELL AS CHANGES IN TECHNOLOGY --
THAT.
HAVE NECESSITATED US TO UPDATE
THE MODEL -- THE BRANCH.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT I EVEN WITH
A NEW MODEL THAT WE WILL BE SEEN
VERY SIMILAR -- THE SAME CHORDS
THAT NEED JUDGESHIPS UNDER OUR
CURRENT MODEL WILL BE THE SAME
CORD SYDNEY JUDGESHIPS UNDER OUR
NEW MODEL.
WE HAVE ARE HAVING TO OVERCOME
MANY YEARS OF NOT HAVING NEW
JUDGESHIPS ALLOCATED BUT AT THE
SAME TIME POPULATION HOUSING
GROWTH -- CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE
TO JUDGESHIP NEED.
DEFINITELY CONTINUE TO
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS.
FINANCE.
A SHIRT AND WEBER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE REQUESTED JUDGESHIPS
HELP ADDRESS JUDICIAL WORKLOAD
NEED TO LET THE COURTS MORE
EFFICIENTLY HERE MATTERS I WOULD
KNOW THAT THEIR QUESTED FUNNY
PROJECT IN THE PROPOSAL IS
CONSISTENT WITH HISTORICAL
FUNDING.
ANY COMMENTS EMILIO I NEED TO
LEAVE AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- WE GENERALLY
DON'T HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
REQUEST WE DID WANT TO NOTE THAT --
UNDER THE JUDICIAL NEEDS
ASSESSMENT A WHILE THERE IS AN
IDENTIFIED NEED OF TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN JUDGES IN SEVENTY
COUNTIES.
THERE'S ACTUALLY A COMPATIBLE
NUMBER OF JUDGES IN OTHER COURTS
THAT ARE IN EXCESS OF OR MORE
THAN WHAT THE ASSESSED WORKLOAD
NEED DEMONSTRATES.
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
GOAL IS TO REDISTRIBUTE JUDICIAL
RESOURCES TO EQUALIZE --
WORKLOAD THE LEGISLATURE COULD
ALSO CONSIDER RE ALLOCATING --
JUDGESHIPS FROM THOSE THAT HAVE
MORE JUDGES AND THEIR THOUGHTS
NEED TO THOSE THAT HAVE LESS.
OKAY MAY COME AS FOR MEMBERS.
EIGHT COMMENTS -- SORRY SOBRE
NOTED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO.
THIS IS A REQUESTED I AM VERY
SYMPATHETIC.
TO AS SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
ASKING FOR FOR YEARS NOW AND
THAT TO TELL YOU WHY I'M SO
PASSIONATE ABOUT IT I'VE BEEN
LEGISLATURE FIVE YEARS NOW BUT
BEFORE THAT.
I WAS MAYOR OF A CITY THAT LOST
ITS COURTHOUSE JUDE DUE TO A
LACK OF JUDGES SO I GOT TO
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND WHAT LACK
OF ACCESS TO JUSTICE MEANS FOR A
COMMUNITY.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I'M SO PASSIONATE ABOUT
MAKING SURE OUR COURTS HAVE THE
JUDGES THAT THEY NEED -- SO THIS
IS IT YOU HEARD THE TESTIMONY
THAT.
JUSTIN SAN MARINO THEY NEED
THIRTY EIGHT MORE JUDGES SO
TWENTY FIVE STATEWIDE IT IS A
GOOD START YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
CONTINUE PUSHING FOR MORE.
BUT CERTAINLY THIS IS GOING TO
BE -- YOU KNOW WELCOME --
WELCOME FIX TO THE SYSTEM ALSO
WANT -- TO TO BE VERY
COMPLIMENTARY THAT THE REQUEST
IT INCLUDES THE STAFF NECESSARY
TO FOR THOSE JUDGESHIPS.
OFFERED FOR THOSE WERE WORK
WATCHING AT HOME ALL ALL TWO OF
YOU.
YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS REQUEST IS
FOR THIRTY SIX AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TWENTY FIVE
JUDGESHIPS AND I'VEACTUALLY
GOTTEN A QUESTION THAT'S OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS PER JUDGE FOR
THOSE JUDGES MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
NO NO NO.
YOU KNOW THIS IS THERE'S A LOT
OF STAFF THAT GOES ALONG WITH
EACH JUDGE YOU KNOW CLERKS AREA
AND WHAT NOT TO MAKE THE WHOLE
SYSTEM FUNCTION AND THAT'S WHY
THIS -- THIS REQUEST IS VERY
REASONABLE AND ALSO TO LASTLY DO
IT ADDRESS THE ALEJO'S COMMENT --
REDISTRIBUTING JUDGES -- I THINK --
THE TERRIBLE WAY OF RESPONDING
THAT WOULD BE -- THAT IT THAT
HAS LOW POLITICAL FEASIBILITY.
SO -- YOU KNOW THIS SEEMS TO BE
LIKE THE BILL THE LOW HANGING
FRUIT THAT WE CAN DO. TO TO YOU
KNOW TO TO ADDRESS THIS NEED IN
OUR IN OUR COURTSHIP SO I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I'M
SORRY -- I'M CERTAIN OKAY.
WE HAVE A JONES SAWYER COMMON
ITEM AND MAKE THIS REAL QUICK
AND I AND I WANT TO ECHO -- THE
SAME -- CONCERNS WHEN I WHEN I
GOT ON THERE WAS A CONCERN.
ABOUT PEOPLE TRAVELING TO COURT
HOUSES THAT WERE CLOSE.
FORGET ABOUT JUST HAVING JUDGES
WE WERE CLOSING COURTHOUSES AND
WE'RE TRYING TO RE OPEN AGAIN.
AND IT WAS YOU KNOW IT WAS
HEARTBREAKING TO HEAR OF OF
PEOPLE HAVING TO TRAVEL.
OF A HUNDRED MILES ON THE BUS.
TO GET ACCESS -- TO CIVIL SUITS
AND AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE
ESPECIALLY WOMEN THAT WERE
BATTERED DATE DID GET ON THE BUS
GO SOMEWHERE.
AND IT WAS CLOSED OR TO HAVE TO
GO EVEN FURTHER.
AND IT JUST SEEMED TO BE AN
ATROCITY SO I IF WE CAN FIGURE
THIS OUT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
GET MORE JUDGES -- ON THE BED SO
WE CAN HAVE A SPECIALLY POOR
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS -- TO THEIR
CASES -- BUT WE WE JUST NEED TO
FIGURE THIS OUT AND GET IT
STARTED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
OKAY IN THE COMING FROM THE
PUBLIC YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M NANCY
TRAVELS CEO OF CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA.
AND TODAY I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF BOTH OUR ORGANIZATION AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF MIKE BELOW FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL
OF OUR COUNTERPARTS.
IN THE DEFENSE BAR -- WE HAVE
BEEN LOBBYING VERY STRONGLY FOR
ADDITIONAL JUDGES FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS.
AND AND WITH OUR NEW GOVERNOR WE
HAVE STRONGLY ADVOCATED WITH HIM
THAT NOW IS FINE WITH THE TIME
TO GET AT LEAST THE TWENTY FIVE
ADDITIONAL JUDGES BY NO MEANS
DOES IT ADDRESS THE NEED.
BUT IT IS A GOOD START AFTER
ONLY HAVING TWO JUDGES.
DO JUDGES APPROPRIATED.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN SO
IT'S A VERY LONG TIME WITH NO
NEW JUDGES.
AND FOR OUR FOLKS WHO DO CIVIL
CASES WHETHER IT'S ELDER ABUSE
OR SEXUAL ASSAULT OR PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN CATASTROPHIC PERSONAL
INJURY CASES THEY HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY BEEN THIS POOR
STEP CHILD.
SENSE CRIMINAL CASES TAKE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PRECEDENT SO WE
HOPE WITH THESE ADDITIONAL
JUDGES THAT THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
VERY IMPORTANT CIVIL CASES WHO
ARE CATASTROPHICALLY INJURED CAN
HAVE THEIR CASES HEARD IN A
TIMELY FASHION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WITH.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AS WELL AS THE RIVER
SIDE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS BOTH
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL.
AND THEY ARE THE TWO HIGHEST
NEEDS COUNTIES WITHIN THE STATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
CONCERNING THE PRINT THIS
PROPOSAL THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD
OPEN I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WAITING
A LONG TIME FOR THE JUDGES SO WE
THINK THIS WILL HOPEFULLY ANSWER
OF BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
ANSWERING THE QUESTION IT'S
THERE.
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER
THAT I ISSUE WILL BE HELD OPEN I
BRING THIS TO ISSUE NUMBER --
TWO WHICH IS DEPENDENCY COUNCIL
TITLE FOR E. FUNDING.
SURE IT'S ALL BE PRESENT ON THIS
ISSUE AS DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES RECEIVES FEDERAL TITLE
FORTY FUNDING FOR CHILD WELFARE
RECENTLY FEDERAL LAW HAS
EXPANDED.
ORDER REIMBURSABLE ACTIVITIES
AND IT NOW INCLUDES COURT
APPOINTED DEFENSE COUNSEL.
SO THE MINISTRATION ALONG WITH
YOUR COUNSEL AND APARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES HAS BEEN TRYING
TO DEVELOP PROGRAMS TAKE FULL
ADVANTAGE THESE FEDERAL
RESOURCES.
AT APARTMENT OF A SERVICES CURLY
ASKED ME TO FILL REIMBURSED
AMOUNT AT THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
THIS A LITTLE FUNDING WILL
INCREASE THE BUT IT FROM A
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN BILLION TWO
HUNDRED NINETY ONE MILLION --
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY IS
PROJECTED LOWER TWENTY CASES
FROM 200-142-0050.
THREE LITTLE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
MISTER THESE RANTS FOR THE JUST
COUNCIL THAT'S MADE AT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS INVOLVES COLLECTED SOME
INVOICES WORKING WITH THE OVER
TO HER FIFTY LEGAL PROVIDERS AND
SOME INFORMATION THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES IN FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
HAPPY TAKE A QUICK THOSE
PROPOSAL IF THERE ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTION ABOUT MANY COUNCIL WE
ALSO HAVE DISCOUNTS.
OKAY FINE OKAY ANY COMMENTS THEM
LA ALL THE COMMENTS AND STAFF.
ANYONE FROM THE PUBLIC.
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME IN THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT AND
IF YOU'RE IN FAVOR OF NOT IN
FAVOR OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU STEVE COULD MAKE THAT
REPRESENTING CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER OF CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT VERY GRATEFUL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
ALSO STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS ANY COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT ITEMS
HELD OPEN AND THAT BRINGS US TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH IS THE
TRIAL COURT RESERVE.
YES THANK YOU AGAIN DOCTOR EVERS
Là CONSIDER WHICH FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL -- THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT A TRIAL
COURT CAN CARRY FROM ONE YEAR
OVER TO THE NEXT YEAR FROM A 1%
THE CURRENT STATUTORY AUTHORIZED
LEVEL 23%.
PRIOR TO TWENTY FOURTEEN TRACK
COURTS HAD THE ABILITY TO CARRY --
ANY RESERVE THEY HAD AVAILABLE --
OVER TO THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR --
BY THE RESTRICTION DOWN 21%
THERE'S BEEN SOME ISSUES IN
TERMS OF BRANCH AND MANAGEMENT
OF A FUNDING -- PAYROLL AND
WHATNOT WE DO AGAIN HAVE --
NANCY ABOUT HERE TO PROVIDE A A
BIT OF A SORT OF LOCAL IMPACTS
ON WHAT THE INCREASING THE CAP
WILL DO TERMS OF BENEFITS TO THE
TRUCK WHAT'S NOT FAIR.
ANY COMMENTS IF.
IN A BILL IT FINANCE EARLY --
NEAR THE COMMENTS MEMBERS.
SOMEBODY SEEMS TO BE HAPPY WITH
IT.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES NATIONALLY IN ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
I WAS STOPPED IN THE HALL BY
SOME JUDGES TO TELL ME THE HIGH
IMPORTANT THIS WAS.
AS I WAS RUNNING THE SOMETHING
ELSE SO IT MUST BE REALLY
IMPORTANT ECONOMY AS I WAS
RUNNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS ITEM
WILL BE HELD OPEN AS WELL.
BRING THIS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS A MEDICAL CLASS
LOCATION MODEL OF DAYS THIS IS A
CD SEE OUR PROPOSAL [inaudible]
ARE YOU.
THIS IS.
THE NUMBERS OF FROM WE HAVE A
LOT OF LA A LITTLE. TOO BUT A
LOT OF PEOPLE WITH THEM THAT'S
FINE [inaudible]
ARE SOME.
OKAY.
NO PROBLEM WILL. FOR LA OPAL
SEPARATE WITH THIS LAWS THEY
DON'T VOTE IT'S OKAY.
YES ALL RIGHT -- GOOD MORNING A
GOOD AFTERNOON RATHER -- CLARK
KELSO RECEIVER -- THE MEDICAL
CLASSIFICATION MODEL -- WE'RE
HIM ON THE GOVERNOR IS -- MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL SEEKS --
HUNDRED AND TWO POSITIONS AND
ABOUT TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND -- BUT TO PROVIDE
INCREASE STAFFING LEVELS FOR
DIRECT PATIENT CARE AN ANCILLARY
HEALTH CARE OPERATIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS.
ABOUT FIVE OR SIX YEARS AGO WE
ADOPTED FOR THE FIRST TIME A
STAFFING MODEL.
OF FOR MARK CLINICIANS UP PRIOR
TO THAT -- BUT BY MY PREDECESSOR
RECEIVER -- WITH -- TRAVEL
AROUND THE STATE AND SIMPLY
DECIDED ON THE NUMBERS.
THERE REALLY WASN'T A SYSTEM A
MODEL WE ADOPTED A MODEL ABOUT
FIVE YEARS AGO -- BUT WE HAVE
SINCE THEN -- ENOUGH EXPERIENCE
WITH THAT MODEL TO REALIZE THAT
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF AREAS FOR
WE HAD.
GAPS -- WE DID NOT HAVE -- AN
APPROPRIATE -- ADDITION TO THE
MODEL FOR A STAFFING WOMEN'S
PRISONS -- WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
MORE PROVIDERS PARTICULARLY IN
WOMEN'S PRISONS WE DISCOVERED
THAT -- WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH.
STAFF TO CARE FOR PATIENTS WHO
HAVE A VARIETY OF DISABILITIES
ON THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT.
AND WE DISCOVERED THAT IN THE
INPATIENT SETTING OUR OUR MOST
OF THE SERIOUSLY ILL -- PATIENTS
WE AGAIN WERE A LITTLE BIT SHORT
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEKING TO DO
HERE IS ESSENTIALLY A JOSH THE
MODEL -- SO THAT WE CAN
COMPENSATE FOR LOW SHORT FALLS
ON A GOING FORWARD BASIS.
IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT FROM
FINANCE.
MICHAEL PLACE BEEN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- WE HOPE TO WORK ON
THIS IS AN ONGOING -- ISSUE AND
ALSO TO BEGIN ADDRESSING THIS IN
THE FUTURE WITH A A REFINED
POPULATION.
OKAY.
BECOMES MELLOW.
LUCAS MORROW THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE NOTE THAT THIS WOULD CHANGE
THE CURRENT -- MEDICATION
CLASSIFICATION MODEL SAID THAT
WHAT NOW IT'S GOING TO BE BASED
ON THE QT LEVELS IN POPULATIONS
IS WITH THE CHEST THOSE RATIOS.
WE NOTE THAT IN PRIOR YEARS THAT
MODEL HAS PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO MEET THE MEDICAL
NEEDS THE POPULATION.
AND A CORN YOUR IT APPEARS THAT.
THAT MODEL HAS NOT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES.
I SUCH A WE FIND THAT IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT THIS MODEL.
NON NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED
CURRENTLY BASED ON THE LIMITED
AMOUNT OF DATA AND ONLY ONE YEAR
ON WHICH IT WASN'T.
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES WE
RECOMMEND PROVIDING THE FUNDING
ON A ONE TIME BASIS. TO ENSURE
THAT THE NEEDS ARE MET. FOR THE
CURRENT YOUR AND ALLOW US TIME
TO IDENTIFY IF THE MODEL NEEDS
TO BE CHANGED ON A PERMANENT
BASIS.
THANK YOU.
AB -- COMMENTS FROM [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
SEC QUICK QUESTION SURE QUESTION.
I STARTED SEVEN YEARS AGO I
THINK THE RECEIVER WAS HERE BUT
YOU ONLY HAD A FEW MORE THINGS
TO WORK OUT.
ON IT TWO YEARS IS MY SEVENTH
YEAR HOW MUCH MORE YOU GOT TO DO.
I AM I WILL NOT REPEAT THE
MISTAKE OF ANSWERING THAT
QUESTION [inaudible]
MARTIN.
MORE SERIOUSLY -- I HAVE
COMPLETED OF THE EVALUATION OF
EIGHTEEN OF THE THIRTY FIVE
FACILITIES AND DELEGATE IN THE
BACK TO THE STATE -- AND I'M
ANTICIPATING A CONTINUING -- BUT
WITH THAT DELEGATION PROCESS SO --
THERE IS.
A PROCESS THAT I HAVE TO GO
THROUGH TO EXIT FROM THE CASE.
PLEASE ABOUT WHERE.
HERE TO YOU OKAY -- WE GOT.
THERE THE LA WAS AS RAISE A
QUESTION ABOUT THE USE OF ONE
YEAR AND SO THAT IT JUST SEEMS
IT QUE THEY WE DO NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL STAFFING THE QUESTION
IS WHETHER NOT THE TRANSIT GOING
TO CONTINUE IN THE MANNER THAT
THEY HAVE -- THAT YOU OFFERED TO
OF THE COVERS ONLY ONE YEAR I
ARE WE LOOKING FOR THE
CONTINUING INCREASE IN POSITION
THIS WILL ONLY HAVE ONE YOUR
DATA WHAT THE DOCTOR WEBER
THOUGH.
THE CHALLENGES WE WE DO KNOW
THAT WE NEED -- WE NEED THESE
POSITIONS.
IF YOU HAVE A ESTABLISH ONLY ON
A ONE YEAR BASIS WE CAN ONLY GO
AFTER ESSENTIALLY A LIMITED TERM --
TYPE OF EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
WHICH MAKES THESE POSITIONS
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE IF IT
TURNS OUT THAT WERE WRONG -- WE
OBVIOUSLY AND WE HAVE OVER
STAFFING AND WE ARE MEASURING
PRODUCTIVITY AND BACKLOGS WE
HAVE A LOT OF DATA THAT CAN TELL
US WHETHER WE HAVE TOO MANY --
WILL CERTAINLY WE WILL COME BACK
AND HAVE THAT ADJUSTED.
END OF THE POPULATION BEGINS TO
DROP FURTHER -- THAT WILL RESULT
IN NATURALLY AND A REDUCTION IN
THE NUMBER OF BUT PROVIDERS SO --
I I THINK WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IS.
LET'S SEE HOW THIS WORKS MAKE
THE ADJUSTMENT ON A PERMANENT
BASIS -- IF THE NUMBER START TO
GO DOWN AND POPULATION NUMBERS
OF PROVIDERS WILL GO DOWN
[inaudible]
HELLO.
I WOULD MAKE TWO COMMENTS ON THE
THE FIRST IS THAT THIS WOULD
JUST BE A APPROVING THAT
POSITION COUNTY BE CHANGE THE
METHODOLOGY SO THAT.
IF THE POPULATION WERE TO GO
DOWN THE NEED WOULD NECESSARILY
GO BACK DOWN BY THE SAME AMOUNT
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE PREVIOUSLY
AT ACTUALLY A DIFFERENT AMOUNT.
I IN TERMS OF THE ONE YOUR BASES
AND LIMITED TERM POSITIONS WILL
NOTE THAT MANY OF THESE
POSITIONS HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT TO
FILL IN THE PAST AND AS A RESULT
THE RECEIVER HAS RELIED ON
REGISTRY POSITIONS.
WE WOULD ANTICIPATE THAT IF THIS
WAS APPROVED ON A ONE YEAR BASIS
THEY WOULD USE THAT FUNDING FOR
REGISTRY SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS COMING FROM
THE UP -- I'M SORRY FINANCE YES --
I WOULD MAKE A PATIENT FROM
FINANCE AGAIN I I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT IN THE SENATE.
THE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND CCGS -- EXPECTED EXPRESSED
ITS WILLINGNESS TO A PROVIDE
ONGOING REPORTING.
IN THE USAGE IF THIS I WERE TO
GO THROUGH IS AN ON GOING
APPROVAL.
OKAY SOUNDS GOOD WE PROBABLY
WILL ALSO THANK YOU -- ANY
COMMENTS NAME AN AGENCY IN
POSITION.
HELEN ROTH DELTON SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND WE REPRESENT THE
WORKERS THE HEALTH WORKERS IN
THESE FACILITIES.
IF YOU DO THESE ONE TIME YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO USE REGISTRY WHICH
IS ABOUT THREE TIMES AS
EXPENSIVE AS A REGULAR POSITION.
YOU HAVE IN THE OUR ENDS I THINK
A 13% VACANCY RATE RHETORICIAN
IS A HUGE PROBLEM SO YOU'RE.
YOU'RE.
USE IT IF YOU DO THIS ONE TIME
AND SO MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE.
AND IF THEY DON'T NEED AS MUCH
THEN THEY THIS WILL JUST BE
TAKING CARE OF THROUGH ATTRITION
BECAUSE IT'S SO HARD TO RECRUIT
GIVEN WHERE THESE FACILITIES ARE
LOCATED IN RURAL AREAS.
THAT IT THAT JUST SEEMS TO BE A
MUCH MORE WASTEFUL WAY OF DOING
THINGS THAN ACTUALLY FILL THESE
THINGS.
AND THEN WAIT FOR ATTRITION
THANK YOU.
ADRIN MOHAMMED WITH THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS
I WON'T BELABOR THE POINT AS THE
ARE YOU JUST SAID BASICALLY WHAT
I WAS GONNA SAY IT MAKES A LOT
MORE SENSE TO HAVE.
CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS FILLED
AS OPPOSED TO BACK FILLING THEM
WITH REGISTRY THAT COST QUITE
FRANKLY THREE TIMES AS MUCH IF
NOT MORE -- WE HAVE HAD A LONG
TERM PROBLEM AND THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE HAVE SEEN IT SOLVED A IN
MANY PLACES -- PLACES SUCH AS
LIKE A STOCKTON BUT STOCKTON PET
THAT'S THE AGE THE AFT IS WITH
ACTUALLY HAVING CIVIL SERVICE
PEOPLE THERE.
DOING THE DOING THE WORK BECAUSE
THEY OWN THE POSITIONS IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN JUST
COME TO AND THEN POSSIBLY LEAVE
FOR THREE MONTHS OUT OF THE YEAR
OR SOMETHING.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE THERE?
THEY THEY HAVE A AN OWNERSHIP
ALIVE AND AND AN OBLIGATION AND
THAT GOES MUCH FURTHER THAN
REGISTRY COULD EVER GO AND SO WE
IMPLORE YOU TO HAVE THIS NOT BE
ONE TIME FUNDING BY ON GOING
FUNDING THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
THIS ITEM TWO IS RECOMMENDED TO
BE HELD OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER.
SIX WHICH IS THE INTEGRATED SAYS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE -- SUBSTANCE USE
SKEWS ME DISORDER TREATMENT
PROGRAM YEAH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S -- A REVISION
INCLUDES -- FUNDING OF SEVENTY
ONE POINT THREE MILLION GENERAL
FUND.
OPERATOR OF NINETEEN TWENTY
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE POINT NINE
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FOR AN INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM --
MEMBERS IS YOU YOU'RE ALL VERY
WELL AWARE ON THEIR HEELS AN
OPIOID CRISIS AND HAS BEEN FOR
SEVERAL YEARS -- THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY -- IN CDC ARE WE'VE SEEN
ON THE SAME RESULTS OF THAT
CRISIS WITH A SPIKE IN THE
NUMBER OF VERY SIGNIFICANT SPIKE
IN THE NUMBER OF OPIOID --
OVERDOSES -- IN THE IN THE
OVERDOSE WAS THAT LEAD TO DEATH --
IT CALIFORNIA'S OF OUR PRISON
SYSTEM -- HAS THE DISTINCTION OF
HAVING THE HIGHEST RATE.
OF OPIOID OVERDOSE DEATHS.
BY FAR OF ANY PRISON IN THE
COUNTRY.
I WORRY WE'RE AT ABOUT THREE
TIMES ARE HIGHER RATES OF OPIOID --
OVERDOSE DEATHS -- OF THE
PROGRAM -- THAT -- HELLO.
IS BEING ASKED FOR IN THIS --
BUDGET PROPOSAL IS BRAND NEW AND
WE HAVE NOT PREVIOUSLY BEEN
ATTEMPTING TO TREAT.
WITH -- MEDICALLY ASSISTED
TREATMENT PROGRAMS -- BUT
PRISONERS WHO HAVE -- OPIOID IT
AND ALL OTHER -- ABUSE ON
DISORDERS -- SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO BUILD A PROGRAM ON LARGELY
FROM THE GROUND UP -- THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ENGAGED IN A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL PLANNING EFFORT --
DRAWING UPON THE EXPERIENCE THAT
WE'VE HAD IN A PILOT PROGRAM.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE OFF
AUTHORIZED ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO
I BELIEVE -- WE'VE DONE A PILOT
IN TWO INSTITUTIONS -- WE HAVE
NOW DEVELOPED SOME EXPERIENCE
AND EXPERTISE IN THE OF WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO A FOR THIS TYPE OF
TREATMENT PROGRAM.
AND WE ARE NOW READY TO ROLL
THAT OUT.
OF THE THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM.
WE WILL BE TARGETING INITIALLY
THREE GROUPS OF PATIENTS.
FIRST OF THOSE WHO ARE COMING IN
TO CDC ARE AND ARE ALREADY ALL
ON OF THIS TYPE OF A TREATMENT
PROGRAM.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN
CONTINUITY OF TREATMENT.
PREVIOUSLY PEOPLE HAVE COME IN
AND WE JUST HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
OFFER THEM THIS TREATMENT.
PROTOCOL SECOND.
I'M GONNA BE TARGETING --
PATIENTS WORTH IN EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OF PAROLE OR RELEASE --
TO SEE IF WE CAN PREPARE THEM
OFF FOR THE TIME WHEN THE GOING
TO WALK OUT THE OF THE GATES AND
BE IN THE FREE WORLD -- AND
HOPEFULLY.
HELP THEM BE IN A BETTER
POSITION.
ON A TO BE SUCCESSFUL UPON
RELEASE I AM NOT TO GO BACK.
TO OF IT USING DRUGS AND WITH
THEM WHICH CARRIES WITH IT BOTH
A HIGHER RISK OF DEATH -- AS
WELL AS A RECIDIVIST.
OF THE THIRD GROUP -- OF
PATIENTS OF WE WILL INITIALLY
TARGET OR THOSE WHO ARE HIGH
RISK -- ABUSERS.
ON THESE WOULD BE PATIENTS WHO
HAVE ALREADY SUFFERED AN
OVERDOSE FOR EXAMPLE WHERE WE
KNOW IT'S VERY LIKELY ONCE
YOU'VE DONE THAT -- MEET YOUR IN
OF A MUCH HIGHER RISK OF
REPEATING -- THERE ARE OTHER
CLINICAL INDICATIONS OF A HIGH
RISK OF THAT WE WOULD BE USING
TO TARGET THOSE -- PATIENTS IN
THE INITIAL ROLLOUT.
I THANK ALL STOP THEIR HAPPENING
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I HAVE WITH
ME DOCTOR AND IT CAME IN -- WHO
HELPED LEAD THE PLANNING EFFORT --
UP FOR THIS PROGRAM.
COMMENTS FROM FINANCE -- CLING
COMING APART A FINANCE --
NOTHING FURTHER OTHER THAN TO
SAY THAT -- THE OVERDOSE DEATHS --
IF YOU KNOW IS A STRIKING METRIC
THAT REQUIRES ATTENTION -- I
THINK -- THE COMMUNITY STANDARD
MOVING FORWARD IF PROVIDING
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
ALMOST AS A HEALTH CARE
DISCIPLINE FOR THOSE THAT NEED
IT -- IS APPROPRIATE TO ADDRESS
THAT KIND OF STUFF --
SIGNIFICANT -- PROBLEM AND WE
THINK THAT THIS PROPOSAL DOES
THAT [inaudible]
COMMENTS MELLOW.
FIGURE THERE SHOULD BE A HANDOUT
THAT WAS PROVIDED TO YOU --
GOING TO PAGE ONE OF THAT --
VIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S ICD T.
PROPOSAL THIRTY WERE PROVIDED A
PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL OVERVIEW OF
THE PROPOSAL I WOULDN'T KNOW.
THAT A LARGE PORTION OF THIS IS
NOT JUST TO INCREASE MA T. BUT
ALSO TO INCREASE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR THERAPY PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS OTHER PROGRAMS AND OR
THE DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING -- SO WE'RE NOTE
THAT IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
THAT WOULD BE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT WOULD INCREASE
BY AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND NOT BE ON
ONGOING BASIS.
GOING ON TO PAGE -- TWO WE
IDENTIFY UMBER OF ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION --
FIRST OF ALL OF THIS WOULD BE A
LARGE SCALE IMPLEMENTATION OF AN
UNTESTED PROGRAM.
WELL ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM HAVE
BEEN FOUND TO BE EVIDENCE BASED
THIS COMBINATION OF SERVICES HAS
NOT BEEN TESTED WITH THESE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS IN MIND --
IN ADDITION SOME ASPECTS OF THE
PROS ALL HAVE NOT BEEN EVIDENCE --
ARE NOT OF IN SPACE AND HAVE NOT
BEEN EVALUATED CORRECTIONAL
SETTINGS FOR INSTANCE ONE OF THE
MEDICATIONS THAT THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD BE USED TO TREAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD -- CODE USED
TO SORT ARE HAS NEVER BEEN
TESTED A CORRECTIONAL SETTING.
THERE IS ONE PILOT OF IT NOT
BEING PROPOSED IN PENNSYLVANIA
HOWEVER DID IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES IT WAS SUPPOSED TO
LAUNCH IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN BUT AS OF THE END OF
APRIL HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
ENROLL ANY.
PARTICIPANTS INTO THE PROGRAM
THAT.
MEDICATION REFERRING TO IS A
LONG LASTING INJECTABLE FORM OF
MOVEMENT OR FEELING WHICH COST
FOUR TIMES AS MUCH AS THE ORAL
PORTIONS OF THE MEDICATION.
IN ADDITION -- THE COST
ESTIMATES IN THIS PROPOSAL
SUBJECT TO SIGNIFICANT
UNCERTAINTY.
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THESE
ESTIMATES WERE BASED OFF OF A
VARIETY OF SOURCES FROM OTHER
STATES AND NOT ARE NOT SO
EFFECTIVE OF CDC OURS POPULATION.
THIS WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE PRICE.
OF THIS PROGRAM GOING.
IN A RANGE OF TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FROM WHAT IS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED EITHER UP OR
DOWN WARD -- IN ADDITION.
THESE ESTIMATES ARE SUBJECT TO
ERROR FOR EXAMPLE THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES FIVE MILLION TO PROVIDE.
NALOXONE TO INDIVIDUALS BEING
RELEASED FROM CDC ARE WITH --
PURITIES DISORDERS -- THAT WOULD
BE ENOUGH FOR TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND OFFENDERS HOWEVER THE
PROPOSAL.
ESTIMATES THAT ONLY FOUR
THOUSAND OFFENDERS HAVE A FEW
IDEAS DISORDERS.
IN ADDITION THE FULL COST OF
THIS IMPLEMENTATION IT HAS NOT
BEEN IDENTIFIED THE PROPOSAL IS.
FOR THREE FIVE THE FIRST THREE
YEARS OF THE PROGRAM HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S NOTED THAT
WOULD TAKE AT LEAST FIVE YEARS.
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM WE'RE
NOT SURE WHAT THE ADDITIONAL TO
YOURS WOULD ENTAIL AND WHAT
RESOURCES WOULD BE NECESSARY.
IT'S ALSO LIKELY THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WILL HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS HAVE NOT
BEEN IDENTIFIED OR INCLUDED IN
THIS PROPOSAL. FOR INSTANCE I
MAY BE A NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
CLASSROOM SPACE FOR THE
COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR THERAPY
PROGRAMS -- THAT COULD ALSO BE
NEEDS FOR ADDITIONAL MEDICATION
DISTRIBUTION INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SPACE FOR THE STAFF IN.
IN ADDITION OUR POTENTIAL
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES WHILE
THE OUR PILOTS RIGHT NOW IN THE
PRESENT AND THREE PRESENTS FOR
MEDICATIONS IS THE TREATMENT.
THIS PROPOSAL IS SUBSTANTIALLY
DIFFERENT FROM THOSE PROPOSALS
AS A RESULT THE IT BERMAN TATIAN
OF THOSE PILOTS MAY NOT
NECESSARILY -- PROVIDE ALL
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THE CURRENT PILOTS --
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL MEDICATIONS
ALSO INCLUDING OVER ALL OF IT
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS AND WOULD BE
A MUCH LARGER SCALE THAN WHAT
THOSE PILOTS ARE -- THIS ALSO
GOES INTO THE RE ENTRY
COORDINATION -- ONLY A FEW DOZEN
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN RELEASED
FROM THE PILOT PROGRAMS AND
WHILE MANY OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE BEEN LINKED TO RE ENTRY
SERVICES.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD BE CREATE A
SEPARATE PROCESS FOR ADDRESSING
RE ENTRY AND IT WOULD BE DOING
SO ON A MUCH LARGER SCALE IT IS
NOT CLEAR THAT.
IT WOULD BE SUFFICIENTLY LINK
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO SERVICES
AND WHETHER OR NOT SOURCES IN
THE COMMUNITY FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
WE ARE NOTE THAT.
GOT THE PROPOSAL SAYS AT FIFTY
SIX COUNTIES HAVE IMPLEMENTED
DIEM CODIS DATA FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES INDICATE THAT ONLY
FORTY COUNTY HAVE IMPLEMENTED
DIEM CODIS.
WHICH IT PROPELLED RIGHT
TREATMENT IN THE COMMUNITY.
IN ADDITION -- WE FIND THAT THIS
PROPOSAL GIVEN LIMITED OVERSIGHT
OVER THE CVT PROGRAMS AND NOTE
THAT A RECENT AUDIT FOUND THAT.
THE CURRENT COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR
THERAPY PROGRAMS WHAT HAD NOT
BEEN EFFECTIVE AT IMPROVING
REHABILITATION AND RECIDIVISM
OUTCOMES FOR OFFENDERS -- THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE INCREASING THE
SIZE OF THESE PROGRAMS AND WHILE
I WOULD CHANGE THE CURRICULUM
AND INCREASED PAIN
QUALIFICATIONS.
FOR THE CONTRACT SOUTH OF THE
PROVIDING THE SERVICES IT DOES
NOT INCLUDE SUFFICIENT OVERSIGHT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE
THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
IMPLEMENTED APPROPRIATELY.
IN ADDITION THE PROPOSAL NOTES
THAT SOME OF THE STAFF MEMBERS
HAVE.
BEEN BRINGING IN CONTRABAND AND
DRUGS INTO THE FACILITIES AND BY
INCREASING THE STUFF IT COULD
ACTUALLY BE TWO MORE CONTRABAND
AND TRYING TO FACILITIES.
I SUCH -- DUTIES CAM SO UNTRUE I
COMMEND THIS IS EMPLOYMENT ON A
PILOT BASIS -- WE AND WE
RECOMMEND DOING SO AT THE THREE
FACILITIES AT CURRENTLY HAVE ANY
T. PROGRAMS IN PLACE AND EXPAND
FROM THAT OUR WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED THE PILOT INCLUDE
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
CONTRACTORS FOLLOW -- THAT BEST
PRACTICES FOR THESE PROGRAMS AND
THAT INDEPENDENT EVALUATION BY
RESOURCES IS DONE TO DETERMINE
THAT THE PROGRAM.
THAT EFFECT ON SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS IN PRISON -- INMATE
HEALTH AND OFFENDER OUTCOMES
UPON RE ENTRY.
AND ALSO INCLUDED OUTCOMES IN
THE COMMUNITY SUCH AS RECIDIVISM
AN OVERDOSE DEATHS.
WE OUGHT ESTIMATE THAT -- PILOT
OF THIS MAGNITUDE WOULD COST
LESS THAN TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND WOULD
BE UNLIKELY TO EXCEED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AT FULL
IMPLEMENTATION.
SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE DECIDE TO
IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE AYE STD T.
PROGRAM RECOMMEND MODIFYING THE
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS -- SUCH
MODIFICATIONS INCLUDE REQUIRING
A MORE GRADUAL IMPLEMENTATION --
AND ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORT FROM
CDC ARE AND THE RECEIVER ON THE
PROGRAM'S IMPLEMENTED
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS.
AN INDEPENDENT EVALUATION ONCE
THE PROGRAM IS FULLY IMPLEMENTED.
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT I WANTED
MENTIONED BECAUSE THERE WAS
BROUGHT UP.
ABOUT OVERDOSE DEATHS IN THE
PRISONS THERE ARE ABOUT FOURTY
OVERDOSE DEATHS THAT LOST YOUR
FRONT.
IN THE PRESENCE OF SOME OF THOSE
WAR OVERDOSE WHICH WOULD LEAD TO
OPIOIDS -- HOW WE NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL ASSUMES THAT A COULD BE
A 50% UP TAKE GREAT -- SET
MEANING THAT 50% OF INDIVIDUALS
WHICH USED TO TAKE MEDICATION
ASSIST TREATMENT AND 50% WOULD
NOT GO INTO IT.
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ACTUALLY REDUCE
OVERDOSE DEATHS AS A RESULT.
WITHIN THE PRISONS THANK YOU.
MANY OF THE COMMENTS THE
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
THIS JONES SAWYER.
I DON'T THINK HE LIKED.
TO YOU ARE RESPOND.
IT OR CAN YOU SHORTEN IT WAS SO
MUCH WELL I GUESS TWO THINGS
THAT WAS THE THERE WAS A LOT
THAT WAS APPARENTLY WRONG WITH
THE PROPOSAL -- I I DID FIND IT
STRIKING THE SUGGESTION THAT.
BY ADDING MEDICAL PERSONNEL TO
TREAT THE DISEASE WE ACTUALLY
WILL MAKE THE PROGRAM WORSE
BECAUSE SOME SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
THEM WILL -- OF SMUGGLE IN DRUGS
THIS IS LA -- REALLY SUGGESTING
THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD SOLVE THE
DRUG PROBLEM BY REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF STAFF.
AT CDC ARE.
THAT'S JUST NOT.
ON A SERIOUS CRITICISM.
I DO THINK THE PROBLEM -- WITH
MOST OF WHAT -- OF THE LA -- IS
SUGGESTING.
COMES DOWN TO THE FOLLOWING.
WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE GREATER
CERTAINTY.
YEAH I'D LOVE TO HAVE MORE
WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE FIFTEEN
OTHER STATES WHO HAVE DONE THIS
BEFORE US.
WELL THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE.
TO ARM WOULD BE NICE.
TO HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT
ARE LIKELY EFFORT TO SEE WHAT IS
GOING TO BE OF THIS PROGRAM YEAH.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT TREATING.
AND WE HAVE THIS YEAR EIGHT
HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVING
OVER GOES.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH.
WE START OUT WITH ANOTHER PILOT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE DONE DOING
SMALL PILOTS THAT REALLY DON'T
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. FOR WHAT
FIVE SEVEN EIGHT YEARS.
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
NOW.
IT'S A BIG.
PROJECT A BIG INITIATIVE.
THERE ARE BIG RISKS ASSOCIATED
WITH IT.
BUT I THINK CDC ARE HAS SHOWN
OVER THE PAST DECADE.
THAT WE CAN DO BIG THINGS.
WE CAN IMPLEMENT LARGE RIGHT T.
SYSTEMS SONGS THE ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD.
WE CAN WOULD COMPLETELY REMAKE
HEALTH CARE.
WE CAN DO TO HELP SEE PROGRAM.
BUT TREATING THOUSANDS OF
INMATES.
SO -- I AM ASKING ON THE
ADMINISTRATION I THINK IS ASKING
FOR SOME TRUST AND CONFIDENCE
THAT WE REALIZE THERE ARE RISKS
HERE.
BUT WE'RE GONNA BE WATCHING VERY
CLOSELY.
UP TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAM
GETS IMPLEMENTED.
OUT CORRECTLY.
WHAT I MAY WANT TO SUGGEST THAT
WE HAVE A A COLLEAGUE -- WHO HAS
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR NEEDLE
EXCHANGE WITH A COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON?
ON THAT I WAS VERY SKEPTICAL
ABOUT AND AND I I MAY HAVE SAID
SOME DISPARAGING THINGS ABOUT.%
HER PROGRAM AND AND THAT THE
STATE IS SANCTIONING.
PEOPLE TO GO AHEAD BASICALLY GET
STATE GET HIGH CENTERS.
AND ONCE SHE FULLY EXPLAIN HOW
IT WORKED ONCE SHE FULLY
EXPLAINED ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE.
IN THESE DIFFERENT PLACES --
THAT WOULD GET PEOPLE OFF THE
DRUGS.
ONCE I WENT TO ONE OF THOSE
CENTERS IN AND SAW IT WAS
EXPERIMENTAL NAME YOU HAVE TO GO
OUT OF THE COUNTRY TO SEE.
WHERE SOMEBODY'S NEEDLE EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS WORK -- ONCE I ACTUALLY
SAW.
AND SAW IT ACTUALLY DID WAS
REALLY MORE OF A DRUG
REHABILITATION PROGRAM THAT
HAPPENED TO PROVIDE.
NEIL CHANGE TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM
KILLING THEMSELVES.
YEAH I TOLD YOU NEED TO SAY IT
BACKWARDS.
NOT THE RIGHT WAY.
AND AND TALK ABOUT THAT BUT THE
TALK ABOUT HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
TREAT PEOPLE HOW SUCCESSFUL IS
GOING TO BE SOME MY
RECOMMENDATION IN IN AN OPENING.
THE LIMITED TIME THAT -- YOU CAN
ACTUALLY MAYBE INVITE.
THE LA -- TO COME OVER AND SEE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO OR ART
OR SIT DOWN AND FULLY EXPLAIN --
THE THE ENTIRE.
TEA UP THE PROGRAM -- AND HOW IT
HAS AN IMPACT ON ON WHAT YOU
WANNA DO IS IT IS IT NEW.
IS IT BEYOND OUR COMPREHENSION
AND THINGS.
YEAH BUT WE WE WE CAN GET OVER
THAT.
YOU KNOW I REMEMBER SEEN STAR
TRAKS A WOULD NEVER HAVE.
FLIP PHONES AND WE WERE BEYOND
FLIP FLIP PHONES HAPPEN WITH.
IT SO I I WOULD SUGGEST AS THE
NEW TECHNOLOGY NEW TREATMENT
WAYS OF TREATMENT THAT.
THE SPINDLE MORE TIME -- TALKING
ONLY.
TO OUR MEMBERS AFTER EVALUATION
PROGRAM BUT ALSO MEMBERS HERE
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT.
GARY OTHER COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
OF ONE OF THE I GUESS ONE OF THE
CONCERNS AND AND AS THIS IS THE
AND WILL BE LOOKING AT THIS IS A
VERY LARGE.
PROPOSAL AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IMPLEMENTING OF ARE YOU A
PROGRAM -- THAT THE I KNOW ONE
OF THEM HAD SOME DIFFICULTY WITH
SUCCESS SO I THINK THE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR PROGRAM ONE OF OUR
STATE AUDITOR'S CONCLUDED THAT --
IT REALLY WAS NOT OF WAS NOT WE
WERE BASICALLY DOING MUCH IN
TERMS OF RECIDIVISMIN TERMS OF
PEOPLE IN THE PROGRAM GETTING
OUT AND NOT BEING A BEING ABLE
TO STAY OUT -- HAVE YOU DRESS
THAT SSUE OR IS THAT GOING TO
BE ADDRESSED THAT'S ONE OF THE
CONCERNS WITH THE PROGRAM TO HIS.
THIS THING IS SO LARGE AND WE'RE
ROLLING IT OUT EVERYWHERE RATHER
THAN IN.
PHASES OR SOMETHING AND ALONG
THE WAY THERE'S BEEN SOME
DIFFICULTY IN TERMS OF OF THE
PROGRAM ITSELF BEING EFFECTIVE
SO THE QUESTION IS HOW ARE WE
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
SUFFICIENTLY TO SAY IT'S NOW WE
CAN GO PRIME TIME YOU KNOW TEMP
THE PROGRAM ITSELF.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS A RAINS IS A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS -- TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I THINK
THIS PROPOSAL FINALIZES ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES THAT WE HAD SEEN
PREVIOUSLY IN TERMS OF
EVERYTHING FROM THE BEGINNING
ASSESSMENTS AND GETTING PEOPLE
INTO PROGRAM.
BY HAVING US CONNECT WITH
MEDICAL AND HAVE THAT REFERRAL
COME DIRECTLY FROM MEDICAL
THROUGH THAT ASSESSMENT PROCESS
REALLY GETTING PEOPLE INTO
PROGRAM WHEN THEY NEED TO BE
THERE AS PART OF THEIR CLINICAL
CARE -- WE HAD INCONSISTENT AND
DISCONNECTED COMPONENTS WE SAT
DOWN WITH EXPERTS AND MEDICAL TO
DEVELOP A CURRICULUM THAT IS
BOTH IN PLACE CONSISTENTLY
DELIVERED ACROSS THIRTY FIVE
INSTITUTIONS AND DO IT DOING
THAT CONSISTENTLY AND
CONCURRENTLY.
SO THE PEOPLE ARE ASSESSING THAT
TREATMENT AND THEN SOME OTHER
THINGS ABOUT CURRICULUM VARIETY
INFIDELITY WE HAD MASSIVE
CURRICULUMS ALL OVER THIRTY FIVE
INSTITUTIONS WERE PUTTING ONE IN
PLACE.
AND WE'RE ALSO PUTTING THE TOOLS
IN PLACE THE MEDICALS BEEN
LEVERAGING THROUGH THEIR
DASHBOARDS WE'VE DEVELOPED
WEEKLY MONTHLY DASHBOARDS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE
OPERATIONALIZE IN IT WE HAVE AN
EXECUTIVE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
THAT'S GOING TO BE HELPING
REVIEW TO MAKE SURE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING -- APPROPRIATELY AND
ACCORDING TO TIME LINES AND DEAR
P. IS VERY WELL VERSED IN --
DOING STATE WIDE EXPANSES ACROSS
THIRTY FIVE INSTITUTIONS WE DO
THAT CONTRACTUALLY NOW SO I
THINK EVERYTHING THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE IN TERMS OF FOUNDATIONAL
OVERSIGHT -- AND THEN OUR
INCLUSION WITH MEDICAL AND
MAKING THIS MODEL WORK TOGETHER --
AND INCLUDING THE REENTRY
RESOURCES REALLY SOLIDIFIES A
PROGRAM THAT CREATES A
CONNECTION FROM IN PRISON ALL
THE WAY TO THE COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S REALLY -- THE CRITICAL
COMPONENT HERE.
OKAY THEIR COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS WITH SYSTEM YES.
POLICIES AS I LOOK AT THIS WHAT
WHAT STRIKES ME IS.
THAT A LOT OF THIS IS WHAT%
CITIES ARE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DOING ALL ALONG.
SO THE FACT THAT YOU'RE COMING
AND ASKING FOR MONEY NOW FOR
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
BUILT IN REALLY.
BUT I UNDERSTAND SORT OF WHERE
WE'VE COME AND WHERE WE'RE GOING.
TO ME THIS IS ONE OF THESE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE NEED TO BE
MAKING IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
SERIOUS ABOUT CLEANING WAS IF
YOU LOOK AT WHY PEOPLE ARE
PRESENT.
A LOT OF IT IS DRUG RELATED A
LOT OF IT IS BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE.
PROGRAMS ENOUGH PROGRAMS OUT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
PRISON.
SO THIS INVESTMENT IT PROBABLY
MAKES SENSE HERE BUT THIS AND
THAT'S WHAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE
REPLICATED.
IN OUR COMMUNITY SO THAT WE
SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS BEFORE IT
BECOMES A PROBLEM.
THAT CDC OUR NEEDS TO TAKE ON ON
ITS OWN.
SO I'M HOPING THIS COMMITTEE
WITH IT WILL TAKE THIS ASK VERY
SERIOUSLY AND REALLY LOOK AT THE
DEPENDENCY ISSUES AND PROVIDE
THAT THAT MECHANISM FOR GETTING
PEOPLE OUT OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
GOT THEM INTO PRISON THE FIRST
PLACE.
THAT'S THE REHABILITATIVE PIECE
THAT HAS LONG BEEN MISSING.
SO I KNOW IT'S A BIG OF EXPENSE
I KNOW IT'S A BIG ASK.
WHETHER IT'S EXACTLY RIGHT HARD
TO TELL I DON'T KNOW YOU WILL
GET THIS IS ONLY WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO EXPERIMENT AND I WOULD
HOPE WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT TO
HAVE FIFTEEN OTHER STATES DO
SOMETHING BEFORE.
WE CAN STEP IN AND IT IT REALLY
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
OTHER STATES ALSO DON'T HAVE THE
SAME LEVEL OF INCARCERATION THAT
WE DO OTHER STATES.
THAT DON'T HAVE HAVEN'T REALLY
CREATED THIS LARGE MASS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET OURSELVES
OUT FROM UNDERNEATH.
SO WHETHER THIS IS RIGHT OR NOT
I DON'T KNOW BUT I THINK WE
SHOULD BE WILLING TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE INVESTING AND
THEN PROVIDING OVERSIGHT AND
GETTING FEEDBACK BACK.
ABOUT HOW THE PROGRAM'S WORKING.
SO THAT CAN BE INGESTED ALONG
THE WAY AND WE SHOULD BE HOLDING
CITIES HERE ACCOUNTABLE TO TO
RESULTS.
OUT OF A PROGRAM LIKE THIS IF
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT THAT'S THIS
SUBSTANTIAL BUT I WOULD HOPE
THIS COMMITTEE.
WOULD DEFINITELY TAKE UP.
A PROPOSAL LIKE THIS SERIOUSLY
AND OF COURSE WORKING WITH THE
SENATE AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT WHAT WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE BUILDING
IN HERE IS ENOUGH.
ABILITY TO GET DATA BACK AND
REALLY.
SHOW SOME RESULTS BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE PAST
FOR US TO IN THE LONG RUN REDUCE
THE PRISON POPULATIONS AND
REDUCE.
THE AMOUNT OF OF THE DRUG THE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE FINDING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO.
I GUESS THAT'S MIGHT THE ONES
THAT I LOOK AT THIS I LOOK AT IS
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
BEING DONE.
ALL ALONG ANYWAY BUT IF WE'RE
GETTING AROUND TO DOING THIS NOW
DOING IT APPROPRIATELY.
LET'S DO IT BUT LET'S DO IT
RIGHT.
OKAY.
GIVE ME THE COMMENTS THE
COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
DIVISION A MINUTE WHEN
ORGANIZATION.
AND YOUR POSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS HAULING
MICHON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
SUSPICION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES FOR THE
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION THAT
PROVIDES SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT
SERVICES -- IN THE COMMUNITY AT
THREE HUNDRED SITES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE -- AND MANY OF OUR
PROGRAMS OPERATE BOTH THE
IMPRISONED AND POST RELEASED
COMMUNITY TREATMENT PROGRAMS --
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT
CAT PEE GENERALLY SUPPORTS.
THIS PROPOSAL WE HAVE LONG
ADVOCATED -- FOR THE INSTITUTION
OF MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
IN PRISON SO WE ARE -- PLEASED
TO SEE THAT -- THAT IT IS NOW --
BEING -- OF INSTITUTED ON A AB
PRISON WIDE BASIS -- WE HAVE A
SUBMITTED.
TO THE COMMITTEE AND TO A C. D.
C. A. R. -- OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
TO STRENGTHEN THE PROPOSAL THAT
HAS BEEN MADE.
BEEN SUBMITTED.
END OF PARTICULARLY THE AREAS OF
BETWEEN -- THE IN CUSTODY
TREATMENT SUCH ISSUES TREATMENT
AND THE MEDICAL AND TO
STRENGTHEN THAT RELATIONSHIP
BECAUSE THE MEDICATION ALONE
DOESN'T GET TO THE TREATMENT IT
ALSO NEED THE COUNSELING AND THE
OTHER PARTS OF IT SO -- IS
SPECIFICALLY THE SUBSTANCE USE
COUNSELING -- SO WE WE HAVE --
ARE INTERESTED IN WORKING WITH
COLLABORATIVELY WITH BOTH THE
CDC ARE AND THE RECEIVER IN
STRENGTHENING.
THAT KIND OF RELATIONSHIP SO
THAT -- THAT TREATMENT SERVICES
ARE SEAMLESS NOT ONLY BETWEEN
MEDICAL AND THE OTHER PERSON BUT
ALSO PRISON SERVICES.
BUT ALSO BETWEEN IN CUSTODY AND
TRANSITION OUT TO THE COMMUNITY --
KID THEN YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES AND THEN THE REST OF IT
WE'VE SUBMITTED THE ONE THE ONE
THING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THE COMMITTEES TIME TO TALK
ABOUT IS.
THE REAL NEED FOR IT INCREASING
THE UP OPPOSED TO RELEASE
SERVICES -- THE MOST.
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING RELEASED
THE MOST CRITICAL TIME IN THEIR
MOST AT RISK TIME FOR RECIDIVISM
IS.
A THIRTY TO NINETY DAYS AFTER
RELEASE AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE IS A SERVICES IN FUNDING
TO PROVIDE NAVIGATION TO GET
PEOPLE TO THE RIGHT SERVICES FOR
THE RIGHT LEVEL OF TREATMENT
THAT THEY NEED -- BUT WE WOULD
ADVOCATE FOR THAT ALSO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY FINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT ITEM WAS ALSO HELD OPEN --
I THINK WE HEAR THAT -- THIS IS
A VERY COMPLEX ISSUE WITH AN
AWFUL LOT OF FUNDING BEING PUT
INTO IT SO HOPE IF IF WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT HOPEFULLY
THERE IS SOME.
IN FROM STEPS TO REPORTING BACK
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE HEADING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND IN THAT
SOMEWHERE.
A LOT OF MONEY SPENT AND NOT THE
RESULTS WE WANT I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO BE EXTREMELY POOR THE
SPECIALLY SINCE IT IS NEW AND WE
HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE WITH NOT
THAT MUCH EXPERIENCE WITH THE
PROPOSAL -- WOULD NOT -- ISSUE
NUMBER SIX WHICH IS THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS [inaudible]
FREEZING.
AS A TEAM NO LONGER FITS INTO.
THE TWO OF THEM [inaudible]
OKAY YEAH -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ARTS WANTS SOME THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF CDC OURS
OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME WE'RE
GONNA.
I KNOW THE AGENDA KIND OF
COMBINES TWO ISSUES SO THAT'S
OKAY WILL INTRODUCE BOTH OF THEM
AT ONCE HERE -- THE DEPARTMENT
IS PROPOSING AN INCREASE OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION AND EIGHT
POINT 8% OF POSITIONS TO
FACILITATE PROPOSED.
REORGANIZATION OF THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY.
THE SECOND PROPOSAL.
IS A PROPOSAL.
TO IS A JOINT ONE ACTUALLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS OF CORPS IT INCLUDES TWO
POINT FOUR POSITIONS AT DJJ.
AN ASSOCIATE GENERAL FUND
TOTALING THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND THE CCC OR
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
REQUEST TO PROGRAM SUPPORTS
STAFF POSITIONS AND ONE POINT
ONE MILLION ONE TIME.
AND FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
THOUSAND ONGOING GENERAL FUND
BEGINNING IN. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE DJJ APPRENTICES CONSERVATION
CORPS PILOT PROGRAM.
AND HERE WITH ME TODAY IS BOTH
THE DIRECTOR AND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE.
CHUCK SUPPLE AND HEATHER BOWLS.
THANK YOU.
YES ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- DOCTOR
WEBER IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I GIVE YOU AN OVERVIEW
OF THE OF THE TWO PROPOSALS ONE
THE REQUEST FOR SUPPORT FOR THE
INITIATION OF THE TRANSITION.
OF DJJ FROM THE ADULT PRISON
SYSTEM -- TO THE TO BE NAMED
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION -- IS
BASICALLY TO ALLOW US TO BEGIN
THE PROCESS OF SETTING UP THE
REALLY ONE OF THE HALLMARKS OF
THIS TRANSITION AND THAT'S THE
TRAINING DEVELOPMENT CENTER TO
BEGIN DEVELOPING -- TRAINING
COMPONENT THAT TRAINS NOT ONLY
THE INDIVIDUALS AND STAFF WHO
WERE INCOMING THE NEW RECRUITS
THAT WOULD BE -- WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH THE YOUTH BUT WHAT
WE DESCRIBE AS THE WHOLE MISSION
FORCES AS A TRAINING CENTER FOR
STAFF YOUTH -- VOLUNTEERS FAMILY
MEMBERS AS WELL SO THAT
EVERYBODY IS TRAIN SUPPORTED ON
HOW TO REINFORCE THE
INTERVENTIONS THE WE HAVE HOW TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH YOUTH AND
ALL TO BE ABLE -- TO PLATE
KRIPKE A CRITICAL ROLES IN
FULFILLING OUR MISSION
[inaudible]
AND THE IN ADDITION THERE ARE
POSITIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
REQUEST THAT ALLOWS US TO BEGIN
TO BRING ON THE LEADERSHIP TO
ESTABLISH SIGNIFICANT DIVISIONS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT ONE
OBVIOUSLY.
HAS TO DO WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE DEPARTMENT --
AS WELL AS ONE THAT WOULD
OVERSEE WHAT WE CALL THE
STRENGTH BASED SPACE THE
POSITIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
ASPECT WHICH IS.
CONCENTRATING ON BUILDING UP THE
ASSETS OF THE YOUTH PARTICULARLY
OVERSEEN -- KATE THE HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION COLLEGE EDUCATION --
THE C. T. E. PROGRAMMING AS WELL
AS BRINGING IN VOLUNTEERS A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS BE
ABLE TO CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOUTH -- THEY'RE GONNA TRANSCEND
FROM OUR FACILITIES DIRECTLY
INTO COMMUNITIES TO ASSIST WITH
THEIR SUCCESSFUL RE ENTRY INTO
THE COMMUNITY AND FULFILLING.
HONORABLE DISCHARGE.
IN THE SECOND A REQUEST -- IT
HAS TO DO WITH A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS AND LOCAL CONSERVATION
COURSE AND THIS IS SOMETHING
WHICH WE CONSIDER TO BE A
NEEDING TO TO RIDE THE BICYCLE
IS WILL BUT AS WE ARE BUILDING
THAT SO TO SPEAK TO BE ABLE TO
BEGIN TO DELIVER ON THE PROMISE.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION BY SHOWING
THE POWER OF PARTNERSHIPS WITH
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO BE ABLE
TO FULFILL OUR MISSION.
AND IN THIS CASE IT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS AS
WELL AS WITH THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES WE HAVE FOUND
THAT -- IT IN BEFORE FOR YOUTH
PLACEMENT IN A CORE UPON RE
ENTRY IS SOMETHING THAT IT MAKES
SENSE IT'S VALUABLE IT
REINFORCES -- MUCH OF THE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES SO WE'RE
HOPING THEM TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE UPON RE ENTRY -- BUT TO
REALLY BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM --
THIS IS A POTENTIAL PLACEMENT
FOR YOUTH COMING OUT OF THE J.
J. THAT WE REALLY HAVE TO CREATE
THE OPPORTUNITY WITHIN DJJ THAT
THEY HAVE TO START IMAGINING.
EXACTLY WHAT IS A CORE WHAT'S IT
MEAN TO BE A CORE MEMBER TO BE
ABLE TO EXPLORE THAT NEW
IDENTITY AND THEN TO BEGIN TO
DEVELOP THE THAT THE PRACTICE IN
THE SKILLS IN THE MINDSET
ASSOCIATED WITH BEING A CORE
MEMBER.
SO THAT WHEN THEY LEAVE THEIR
CHANCES OF BEING ABLE TO BE
PLACED IN EITHER A LOCAL COR OR
THE CCC.
ARE -- SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED I
KNOW CHALLENGES BEEN WITH THE
LOCAL COURSE HAVING YOUTH OFF
THE STREET BE COR READY WE HAVE
A POPULATION OF YOUTH WHO HAVE
TIME -- IT TO BE ABLE TO BE
DEVELOPED AND PREPARED TO BE
CORPS READY -- IMMEDIATELY UPON
RE ENTRY TO THE COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S THE TYPE OF PARTNERSHIP
THE WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD AND
DEMONSTRATE -- AS A PART OF THIS
NEW DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION FOLLY BUT
THAT IS A GENERAL OVERVIEW AND
BOTH SOCCER BALLS MYSELF FOR HER.
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS INTO A
RESPOND MORE SPECIFICALLY TO
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OKAY. THREE COMMENTS FROM
FINANCE.
HELLO.
WOW OKAY.
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
YES MISTER STONE.
YES AND IN IN APPRECIATE THE
DIRECTION YOU'RE GOING BUT AGAIN
I WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT IF
WHAT YOU FALL WE'RE DOING IS
TAKING.
CONCEPTS OUT OF DJJ AND DROPPING
THEM INTO THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WORLD.
WE POTENTIALLY MISS A REAL
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO SERVE.
KIDS WHO ARE STRUGGLING AND KIDS
WHO NEED OUR HELP KIDS WHO ARE
AT PROMISED USE MINE FROM
COLLEAGUES TERM.
AND AND REALLY LOOK AT AT WHAT
THEY NEED AND SO WITH SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE AND SOME OF THE THE
CONCEPT IF WE'RE IF WE'RE REALLY
NOT BUILDING IN THERAPEUTIC
REHABILITATIVE MODELS AND ALL.
AND STILL HANGING KIDS IS BEING.
THE YOU KNOW THE BAD KIDS THAT
MAYBE THERE'S SOME REDEMPTION AS
OPPOSED TO KIDS WHO REALLY
STRUGGLE KIDS WHO OF WHO HAVE.
BEEN TRAUMATIZED AND GONE TO
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
AND THAT'S WHERE THE THE THE
REASON THAT THAT I WOULD HOPE WE
WERE BRING THEM.
INTO THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WORLD.
AND SO ONCE THAT HAVING A A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM WHICH IS
NOT NECESSARILY YOUR ROLE IN
THIS BUT OF A PIECE OF IT BUT
I'M HOPING THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL GO FURTHER.
IN DESIGNING A PROGRAM THAT
ADDRESSES ISSUES THAT KIDS NEED
IN ORDER.
TO TO NOT BE IN TROUBLE THE
FIRST PLACE TO GET OUT OF
TROUBLE. TO BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT THEY DID ABSOLUTELY BUT A
DRESS THE UNDERLYING ISSUES THAT
THEY HAVE THAT GOT THEM IN THAT
SITUATION IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND THAT'S YOU'RE TAKING KIDS
WHO HAVE MADE THAT MISTAKE AND
NOW.
WE'RE REHABILITATING THEM.
IN HOPEFULLY THE BEST OF WAYS
BUT WE SHOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF KIDS WHO
ARE.
STRUGGLING IN THEIR COMMUNITY
STRUGGLING WITH AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND AND BE ABLE TO WRAP SERVICES
AROUND THEM SO THAT THEY DON'T
END UP IN.
IN SITUATIONS WHERE THEY ARE IN
TROUBLE SO. TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE WE GLOBALLY AND AND YOUR ROLE
THIS SPECIFIC TO THE KIDS WHO
ARE JUVENILE JUSTICE AND AND
COMING OUT OF THAT BUT TO THE
EXTENT WE STILL.
TREAT THOSE KIDS DIFFERENTLY AT
AND CATEGORIZE THEM DIFFERENTLY
THAN I THINK WE'RE NOT SERVING A
BROADER MISSION THAT WE POSSIBLY
CLICK HERE.
SO I HOPE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION.
LOOKS BEYOND WHAT THIS SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL IS A LOOK AT THE
OPPORTUNITY BE ABLE CIRCUITS
BETTER.
IN ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
WHETHER OR NOT THEY COME INTO.
THE PURVIEW OF OF THE STRUCTURE
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'VE
HAD THIS CONVERSATION BEFORE I
JUST WANTED TO GO.
BACK ON THE RECORD FOR THAT
BECAUSE I I THINK WE'RE REALLY
ON THE CUSP OF SOMETHING THAT IS.
SIGNIFICANT AND CAN BE
TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL.
BUT I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK
AT THE ENTIRE POPULATION THAT'S
THERE NOT JUST KIDS HAVE DONE
SOMETHING WRONG.
AND GOT WRAPPED UP IN THAT BUT
ALSO KIDS WHO ARE.
WHO NEED US TO STAND UP FOR THEM
AND AND GET A BETTER LEVEL OF
SERVICES I KEEP HOPING THAT THIS
CONVERSATION WILL BROUGHT?
AS WE GO THROUGH THIS INTO BEING
ABLE TO REALLY PROVIDE A COMMON
SET OF SERVICES FOR ALL KIDS WHO
ARE SIMILARLY SITUATED IN NEED
US TO HELP THEM.
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
WITHIN THEIR FAMILIES THRIVE AND
INTO MUCH BETTER SO THAT WE
DON'T END UP HAVING.
TO RESTORE THEM WE DON'T END UP
HAVING -- TO THE TOW HAVE THEM
ATONE FOR THE MISTAKES THAT THEY
MADE BUT I DO WE NOT MAKE THE
MISTAKES.
IN THE FIRST PLACE WILL BE
ASSISTED OUT OF THAT SO I THIS
IS THIS IS INTERESTING WILL WILL
ABSOLUTELY SEE WHERE THIS GUY
WAS AND THEY HAD. ONE THAT I'M
HOPING THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE.
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BUT THERE'S A
LOT MORE TO DO HERE THAT I THINK
ARE JUST.
LOOKING AT THIS -- FIRST BLUSH.
COMMENTS IN THE AUDIENCE ELEVEN
FROM WELL I'M SORRY.
JONES SAWYER.
AND I AND I HAVE A CONCERN TO
ANNA AND I HOPE -- BECAUSE I
READ THIS IS THIS KIND OF HAS
THE SAME CHALLENGE I HAD.
WITH THE THIRTY SEVEN MILLION.
THAT I GOT.
FOR FOR ACES TRUMP FORM CARE THE
BUREAUCRACY.
IN THEIR MYOPIC VIEW OF HOW YOU
DEAL WITH YOUNG PEOPLE CAN'T GET
OUT OF THEIR WAY.
AND THIS KIND OF SOUNDS LIKE
THAT AT THE YOU KNOW I AND I
HOPE YOU'RE NOT WEDDED TO THIS.
CRADDICK DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION BECAUSE
THAT KIND OF CAPS LATE WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS.
AND EVEN AS I READ THROUGH HERE --
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING I
DON'T KNOW WHAT.
THE HECK THAT MEANS BUT I DO
KNOW WHEN I'VE TALKED TO
FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
AND INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
THEY TALK ABOUT TRAUMA.
GET THE EXPERIENCE WHEN THEY
WERE YOUNG YOUNGER.
AND AND HOW THAT LED THEM INTO
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE
AND THAT THERE WASN'T ANYONE
THERE THAT DEALT WITH THAT
TRAUMA AND IF THEY HAD SOMEONE
JUST DEALING WITH THE TRAUMA
ALONE.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A HUGE HELP
IN THE BE ABLE.
TO READ EFFECTIVELY BEEN REDUCED
RATE LEVEL TO BE ABLE TO DO MATH
AND OTHER SKILLS THAT WE JUST
KIND OF TAKE FOR GRANTED.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO REALLY
DELVE INTO.
THE PSYCHE OF WHAT GETS ME TOO
YOUNG PEOPLE IN A BECAUSE WE
KEEP IGNORING IT.
ALL OF THESE BASIC PROGRAMS
WON'T MEAN ANYTHING -- AND EVEN
SOME OF THEM YOU KNOW FIRST AID
AND CPR CUSTOMER SERVICE LEVEL
TRAINING.
OSHA TRAINING -- I I DIDN'T.
I DON'T SEE ANYTHING.
WHERE WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT
MAYBE EVEN GETTING THEM TO
COLLEGE OR TRYING TO GET THEM
INTO A?
BUT A REAL TRADE OR EVEN TRYING
TO GET THEM INTO THE COMPUTER
ENGINE SO WHERE LEARNING CODING.
SO THEY CAN GOAL OF IT BEYOND
[inaudible]
JUST.
SUPERFICIAL MENIAL BANKS AND
PASSED AND SO -- I'M I'M HOPING
THAT.
YOU KNOW IF YOU IF YOU NEED
MISTER STONE IN MY HELP WE CAN
WE CALL SOME NAMES OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
I THINK WILL BE A LITTLE MORE.
UPLIFTING.
AND DOESN'T FEEL LIKE YOU MOVE
ME FROM THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM INTO ANOTHER JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
BUT YOU'RE ACTUALLY PUTTING IN A
PLACE WHERE AS THE TERM I'M
TRYING TO USE NOW THAT IS THAT
PROMISED THAT YOU.
LIKE HERE.
AND MOVING UP AND I KNOW YOUR
YOUR HEART'S IN THE RIGHT PLACE
I KNOW YOU WANT TO GET THERE AND
AND IF YOU NEED US.
HERE TO BREAK THE CHAINS OF THE
BUREAUCRACY WERE WILLING TO HELP
YOU WITH THAT BECAUSE I ALSO
KNOW -- YOU PROBABLY HAVE SOME
INNOVATIVE IDEAS OF THINGS THAT
YOU WANT TO DO.
BUT YOU MIGHT BE CONSTRAINED TO
YOU PROBABLY CAN'T TELL ME NOW
YOU TELL ME LATER WHEN NOBODY IS
LISTENING -- I WOULD SAY
ANYTHING TO ANYBODY I PROMISE.
OF HOW YOU WOULD WANT TO EXPAND
THIS.
IN A WAY THAT NIGHT I THINK YOU
PROBABLY WOULD BELIEVE WOULD BE --
MORE BENEFICIAL TO THE YOUNG
PEOPLE OF THAT.
MAYBE THE TRADITIONAL OF
BUREAUCRACY JUST CAN'T.
SEEING THEIR WAY TO APPROVING IT
REMAIN FUNDED -- BUT IF WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THIS TO THE NEXT
LEVEL WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO SO --
SIMULATOR.
OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS TO MAKE
ANY OF COME FROM THE AUDIENCE
ANY.
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
AGENCY AND WHETHER YOU'RE IN
FAVOR OF OPPOSED TO IT.
YES -- WORKING CONVENE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS IS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO MATEO AND SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND ONE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
TO AND IN FACT.
WE'VE SPOKEN -- TO MISTER SUPPLE
AND TWO CD C. R. ABOUT THEIR
ABOUT -- THIRTEEN THOUSAND
PRISONERS WITHIN CDC ARE UNDER
THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE WHO MIGHT
REALLY BENEFIT FROM THIS SORT OF
REHABILITATIVE THERAPEUTIC
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE CREATING
IN DJJ A LOT MORE THAN IT'S YOU
SEE ARE.
SO WE'RE HOPING THAT WE CAN KEEP
THAT PATHWAY OPEN WE CAN MOVE
SOME OF THOSE PRISONERS WHO ARE.
UNDER AGE TWENTY FIVE INTO THIS
REHABILITATIVE ENVIRONMENT AS
PART OF THIS PROCESS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE -- IT I I I WANT TO
SAY THAT I THINK -- THESE
PROPOSALS -- WHICH IS GOOD OF
OBVIOUSLY WITHOUT WITH THE
SUPPORT OF FINANCE IN LA -- THE
CONTROVERSY IS NOT THERE IN
TERMS OF WHERE THE MONEY IS AND
HOW WE USE IT IN WITH HIS GETS
AS WERE IT YOU GUYS ON THE SAME
PAGE AND BE COMMENDED.
I LET'S SAY BOTH OF YOUR WRONG
THOUGH SO THAT MAKES ME FEEL
BETTER BUT NO I'M JUST TEASING
BUT I AM CONCERNED HOWEVER
THOUGH THAT.
WHEN THIS PROPOSAL CAME FORWARD
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT WE
WORKED ON SO MANY ISSUES BEFORE --
WITH THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO IMPROVE
AND WHAT HAVE YOU.
THAT -- I THINK IT'S GREAT THAT
WE SAID WE WANTED DIFFERENT
SYSTEM. ONE A SYSTEM THAT IS --
THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN THE
CURRENT SYSTEM AND WE'VE BEEN
PROMISED AT THAT -- THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ENDING THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AS WE KNOW WHAT
ONCE AND FOR ALL THOSE ARE THE
WORDS OF OUR GOVERNOR AND THAT'S
A REALLY GOOD STATEMENT.
THAT'S THERE I THINK IT TAKES A
LOT MORE TIME TO DO THAN WHAT
WE'VE HAD TO DO IN TERMS OF TIME
TO DO IT -- I AM CONCERNED AS
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES TO MENTION.
THAT -- I DON'T WANT TO BE THIS
TO BE THE LATEST AND GREATEST BY
AT THAT WE DO.
AND WE DID IT WITH THE SAME
RESULTS BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE DONE
IS MOVE FROM YOU KNOW A ROOM
THAT'S NOW BROWN AND TURNED IT
INTO A ROOM THAT'S PINK OR
GREATER ORANGE OR SOMETHING.
IN THAT SENSE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
LATCHED ON TO THINGS THAT ARE
OUT THERE WITHOUT REALLY
CAREFULLY ANALYZING WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
I DON'T HAVE A VISION AT THIS
POINT AND I'M AND I DON'T STILL
DON'T SEE A VISION OTHER THAN
WORDS BUT I DON'T REALLY SEE.
A CLEAR VISION OF WHERE WE'RE
GOING WITH THIS WHAT IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE -- WE HAD SOME OF THE
ADVOCATES COME IN BEFORE AND
THEY'VE TALKED ABOUT.
A NUMBER OF THINGS AND THEY ARE
UP TO THEY ARE BASED AT ONE
POINT OPTIMISTIC AND SKEPTICAL
AT THE SAME TIME BECAUSE I THINK
THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH LIKE MOST
FOLKS HAVE.
A WHOLE LOT OF DIFFERENT CHANGES
YOU KNOW COMES IN AND YOU'RE
GOING TO DO THIS FOR US IS THAT
AND YOU CHANGE THE BUILDING.
IN TERMS OF MEN NOT MAKING LOOKS
SO MUCH LIKE A PRISON OR YOU
CHANGE THIS YOU.
THAT AND IN THE END THE RESULTS
OF THE SAME STILL NOT MEETING
THE NEEDS OF KIDS WERE STILL
SEEING HIGH LEVEL OF RECIDIVISM
WE'RE STILL SEEING A JUVENILE
JUSTICE PROGRAM BASICALLY BEING
THE PIPELINE TO THE HARDCORE
PRISONS OR WHATEVER MAYBE.
SO I'M LOOKING.
FOR A PLAN OF WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO I'M NOT SURE WE'VE
MENTIONED WE WANT TO USE OUR
ADVOCATES WE WANT.
TO BRING THEM INTO THE PROCESS
AND AND YET I DON'T SEE A WAY IN
WHICH THEY'RE BEING.
TRULY INCORPORATED IN THE
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION ON
AN ONGOING BASIS -- IT SEEMS TO
ME IF I WERE GOING -- TO CHANGE
A SYSTEM AS LARGE AS THIS.
AND AS IMPORTANT AS THIS.
I WOULD BE PLANNING IT ON A
REGULAR BASIS MORE THAN FROM
JUST FROM JANUARY TO WHAT IS
THIS MAY.
OF MORE THAN FIVE MONTHS TO
CHANGE THE WHOLE SYSTEM.
I THINK THERE ARE ALSO A LOT OF
THINGS THAT -- THE THAT I'VE
SEEN IN TERMS OF THE JUVENILE
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE BEEN -- THAT
HAVE TAKEN TIME IN TERMS OF
TRANSFORMATION NOT ONLY IN TERMS
OF OF WHAT OUR VISION IS WHAT
THE KIDS SHOULD BE DOING WHAT IT
SHOULD LOOK LIKE.
BUT ALSO WHO SHOULD BE DOING IT.
YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT THOSE
THERE'S A WE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE
THERE'S A BIG PUSH TO SIMPLY
SHIFT THE CURRENT EMPLOYEES INTO
THE CURRENT SYSTEM TO THE NEW
SYSTEM.
AND MOVE ON FROM THERE AND THAT
COULD BE THE WORST THING IF WE
BUILT A SYSTEM AROUND CURRENT
EMPLOYEES NOT THAT CORN
EMPLOYEES ARE BAD BUT WHEN YOU
SOMETIMES CHANGING THE SYSTEM.
THE RECOGNITION COMES REAL SOON
IS THAT.
CAN THESE FOLKS ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT A NEW SYSTEM THAT THEY
ARE SO COMMITTED TO THE OLD
SYSTEM ABOUT DOING.
AND AND IS IT JUST WINDOW
DRESSING WAS IT REALLY
SUBSTANTIVE IN TERMS OF CHANGE
SO.
I YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT OUR
RECOMMENDATION IS GOING TO BE
BUT I CAN ENVISION SOMETHING
THAT HAS MORE OF AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT WORKS ON THIS
PROBLEM FOR US.
IT REALLY GETS US TO DO IT RIGHT
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT HAPPENS IF
WE DON'T DO IT RIGHT.
THEN WE COMMIT OURSELVES FOR
WHATEVER CRAZY REASON THE WAY WE
FEEL. TO DOING IT AS TO THE
LEVEL WAS YOU YOU PROBABLY HER
WHAT WE'VE ALREADY SPENT SO MUCH
MONEY ON A PAINT IN THIS ROOM SO
LET'S JUST KEEP RIGHT YOU KNOW
IS UGLY BUT WE LIKE IT ANYWAY
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS BEEN OUR MONEY
ON IT.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE BEEN.
YOU KNOW BETTER THAN STEPPING
BACK AND SAID I DON'T CARE HOW
MUCH WE SPENT ON IT WE GOT TO
MAKE SOME CHANGES AND SO.
I I WANT US TO BE I'M NOT
LOOKING FOR SOMETHING THAT'S
REALLY VERY DEEPLY THOUGHTFUL
THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES ARE TALKING ABOUT
WE'RE ALL EXCITED ABOUT CHANGING
AS WELL EXCITED ABOUT.
DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT WITH
OUR KIDS AND AND IT AND IT
REALLY IS -- AND I'VE SEEN
THINGS AS I POINTED OUT LAST
TIME I I I WENT TO A JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN GHANA AND IT
WAS SO VERY DIFFERENT THAN HERE.
AND BASED ON THE VALUES OF THAT
COUNTRY AND IT'S PERSPECTIVE OF
YOUNG PEOPLE AND FAMILIES AND
AND LOOKING AT WHAT HAD HAPPENED
AS REALLY A REFLECTION.
OF THEIR VALUE SYSTEM GOING AWRY
YOU KNOW THAT THEY YOU KNOW THAT
THEY BELIEVE THAT AT CERTAIN AT
BURKE CERTAIN THINGS HAPPEN AND
FROM HERE GOES TO HEAR AND GO
SIT THERE.
AND AND AND AND THE FAMILY
PARTICIPATES IN THIS PROCESS SO
WHEN THEY LOOK AT SOMETHING AS A
THIRTEEN OR FOURTEEN YEAR OLD.
WHO'S STEALING SOMETHING OR
WHATEVER THEY ARE SAYING TO
THEMSELVES WE'RE IN THIS PROCESS
OF WHAT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO DO
DID WE GO WRONG AND HOW DO WE GO
BACK AND REPAIR THAT PROCESS.
HOW DO WE INCORPORATE THOSE KIDS
IN THE FAMILIES INTO THIS
PROCESS AND SO THERE'S A SO
DIFFERENT WHEN YOU WALK INTO A
TO SEE A DIFFERENT PROCESS
TAKING PLACE?
YOU SEE A REAL DIFFERENT KIND OF
REUNIFICATION IT IS A DIFFERENT
KIND OF REFLECTION ON FAMILY AND
PEOPLE SO.
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE FIGURE OUT WHAT WHAT WHAT
WE REALLY NEED TO BE DOING IN
THIS BECAUSE THIS IS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY.
AND I DON'T WANT TO BE
SQUANDERED BECAUSE SIMPLY WE
JUST MOVE KIDS FROM.
MOVE THE DESIGNATION IN OTHER
WORDS THE THE THE THE NUMBERS WE
HAVE WHEN WEGET PAID MAYBE YOU
YOU'RE NOW IT YOU KNOW THE ONE
OLE OLE SEVEN FIVE IS THE NUMBER
THAT YOU HAVE NOW YOU HAVE ONE
OLD.
SEVEN EIGHT OKAY AND AS A RESULT
NOT YOU CHECK COMES FROM THIS
GROUP DOES THAT GROUP AND WE'RE
DOING THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER SO.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THAT VERY
MUCH SO NOT CONCERNED ABOUT YOU
BUT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT HOW MUCH.
THE PROCESS IS WHETHER NOW WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN THOUGHTFUL IN THE
PROCESS AND WHAT WOULD HAVE
ENOUGH TIME. TO BE THOUGHTFUL IN
THE PROCESS AND I DON'T WANT TO
MAKE. TOO MANY COMMITMENTS TOO
SOON BECAUSE IF YOU DO WITHOUT
THAT THEN WEEK WE'RE COMMITTED
TO THAT.
AND YOU KNOW HOW THAT GOES WITH
THE SYSTEM GOES ON AND ON AND ON
UNTIL YOU FIGURE OUT IT'S WRONG.
AND THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PROCESS BECAUSE IT INVOLVES THE
LIVES OF YOUNG PEOPLE AND IS
ALSO UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO ASSESS AND WE ASSESS
OURSELVES.
AND REALLY PUT SOMETHING IN
PLACE THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
TO YOUNG PEOPLE SHOULD TAKE A
LOT OF TIME.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN DO IT
IN FIVE MONTHS I'VE MET YOU KNOW
AND AND I THINK I'M PRETTY
AWESOME.
BUT BUT YOU KNOW JUST IN TERMS
OF OF OF MAKING SURE THAT ALL
THE FOLKS WHO KNOW SOMETHING
ABOUT OUR KIDS WORK.
WHAT IN THE COMMUNITIES IN WHO
ARE WORKING WITH THEM -- CAN CAN
REALLY WRAP THEIR ARMS AROUND
AND GET THIS PROCESS GOING SO
THAT WAS MY CONCERN FROM THE
DATE COULD POPPED OUT AND I SAID
OKAY PRETTY SOON I'M GONNA SEE
SOME.
HUGE COMMITTEE REPORT ON ONE SEE
SOME FOLKS HAS BEEN WORKING
OVERTIME AT NIGHT MORNINGS AND
MAYBE IT'S HERE.
BUT I'M GOING TO SEE THAT AND
I'M GOING TO HAVE FOLKS WHO
ABOVE REALLY BITE INTO IT AND
AND AND TELLING ME HOW IT'S
GOING TO ROLL OUT IN PARTS AND
PIECES.
YOU KNOW -- SO THAT'S WEEK
THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING AT AND
AND I AM TOTALLY COMMITTED TO
THIS CHANGE.
BUT I WANTED TO BE REAL.
I WANT TO BE REAL AND I DO THINK
YOU DO TOO RIGHT.
AT THE RISK OF RESPONDING TO NOT
A QUESTIONS THAT OR EVEN TOTAL
SURE DOESN'T ASK A QUESTION
DON'T TALK YEAH -- AND I
APPRECIATE DR WEBER WHERE YOU
ARE COMING FROM -- I DO WANT TO
SAY THAT I SEE THIS AS IT'S AN
ONGOING JOURNEY.
IS NOT THE BEGINNING OF A
JOURNEY AND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND PAST ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE
INVESTED A LOT OF MONEY IN THE
REFORM OF DJJ.
AND THAT THERE HAVE BEEN THERE
HAS BEEN A LOT OF MONEY IN
DEVELOPING THE INTEGRATED
BEHAVIOR TREATMENT MODEL WHICH
DR BOWLS WAS VERY MUCH INVOLVED
WITH ALONG WITH A NUMBER OF
OTHER COLLEAGUES.
THAT HAS DEVELOPED.
OUR CAPACITY UPON WHICH WE NEED
TO BUILD TO ADDRESS THE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES IN THE
TRAUMAS IN THE ISSUES UNDERLYING --
THE BEHAVIORS THAT BROUGHT A
YOUNG PERSON TO DJJ.
AND THAT.
THE MOVE THE PROPOSAL TO MOVE IT
TO THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES IS PART OF THAT
JOURNEY TO BE IN A PLACE WHERE I
CAN FURTHER REINFORCING DOUBLE
DOWN OUR ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER THOSE SERVICES TO
ADDRESS THOSE UNDERLYING NEEDS.
AND THE SECOND PART OF THE
JOURNEY WHICH WAS NOT PART OF
THE THE PRINCIPAL PART OF THE
FOR A LAWSUIT IS IS THIS NEW
FRONTIER WITH REGARD TO JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
THE AT PROMISE YOU THE BUILDING
UP UPON THE STRENGTH NEEDED TO
SAY THIS IMPRESSIVE YEAH THE
CUTTING EDGE THERE BECAUSE IT IS
THE EXACT IT'S IT'S YOU TRIBUNE
I'LL JUST IN TERMS OF SEEN YOUTH
NOT AS SOMEBODY WHO.
COMES IN JUST A HANDFUL OF
DEFICITS BUT SOME STRENGTH
BECAUSE OF ADVERSE EXPERIENCES
CAN YOU KNOW SOCIAL ECONOMICAL
SITUATIONS IN TERMS OF THEIR
UPBRINGING.
THE STRING TWENTY WILL BE BUILT
UPON BUT TO BUILD UPON THEM
WITHIN DJJ SO THAT THEY CAN NOT
ONLY HAVE ADDRESSED REDUCE THE
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH BEHAVIOR
BUT HAD BEGUN LIVING IMAGINE A
NEW LIFE.
THE PARTNERSHIPS WHICH WE HAVE
REACHED OUT AND INVOLVED MANY OF
THE ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS IN IN
ACTUALLY DELIVERING THE SERVICES.
HAS BEEN A PRINCIPAL PART OF OF
SOME OF THESE OTHER PROPOSAL
THAT YOU'VE SEEN AS A PART OF
THE A PART OF THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL AND SO WHAT WE HOPE TO
BRING TO YOU.
IS CERTAINLY A YOU KNOW DYNAMIC
AND HOUSE OF ENHANCEMENT AND
BUILDING UPON -- THE DISTANCE WE
HAVE COME SO FAR SURE THE NEXT
PART OF THAT JOURNEY AND OF
COURSE WE'RE GONNA REACH OUT
INVOLVED THE STAKEHOLDERS MANY
OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY PROVIDING
SERVICES.
IN DJJ TODAY AND I THINK THAT --
A LOT OF PEOPLE WILL TELL YOU
THAT THEY COME IN AND VISIT D.
J. J. AND ARE LIKE.
WOW.
THIS IS A LOT DIFFERENT THAN DJJ
OF THE PAST WHAT IS NOT
DIFFERENT ENOUGH IN TERMS OF
WHERE WE NEED TO GO AND WE THINK
THAT THIS IS GOING TO ADVANCE
THAT JOURNEY SIGNIFICANTLY SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO
BRING TO YOU -- THE RESULT OF
THAT INPUT THE RESULT OF THAT
PLANNING TO SEE THAT MEET YOUR
EXPECTATIONS.
WELL WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
BECAUSE I THINK AS A COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO YOU KNOW LOOK TO
SEE WHAT DATA IS BEING COLLECTED.
WHAT THE RESULTS ARE WHERE YOU
ARE IN THE PROCESS I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE?
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN BASICALLY
GIVEN THIS PROPOSAL IN IN
JANUARY NOW HERE IT IS WE'RE
GONNA MAKE THIS CHANGE.
AND MOST OF US HAVE BEEN LOOKING
FOR THE FULL BLOWN.
DOCUMENT OR PLAN OR WHATEVER IT
IS AND MAYBE IT IS IN ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS.
BUT BUT I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT I LIKE I SAID AND I
THINK IT'S NOT CONTROVERSIAL IT
TO THE EXTENT THAT WERE ALL IN
FAVOR OF IT YOU KNOW -- OF THAT
WE WANT THIS TO HAPPEN WE THINK
IT CAN'T HAPPEN HAS TO HAPPEN
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE --
AND WE'RE GOING TO BETTER BUDGET
BUT NOT ONLY THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT THE OVERALL
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE -- NCDC
ART EVERYBODY ELSE BUT OF SO I
THINK IT WILL BE IMPORTANT AT
YOUR CONSULATE GIVING US
INFORMATION.
AW AND OUT OF ABOUT IT WE'RE
GONNA PROBABLY MAYBE ASKED IT
MAY EVEN HOLD A HEARING TO FIND
OUT WHERE WE ARE.
BEFORE THE BEGINNING OF NEXT
YEAR SESSION TO GET A SENSE OF
WHERE YOU ARE IN THIS PROCESS
WITH THE HOLES ARE -- BECAUSE IS
IT JUST THAT IMPORTANT IN IF
THERE'S A NEED.
FOR US TO BE MORE ENGAGED IN
TERMS OF FINANCES OR THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS ARE.
I THINK IT WILL BE IMPORTANT SO
WE'RE NOT JUST GOING TO SAY OKAY
YOU GOT IT GOAL HERE'S THE MONEY
HAVE A HAVE A BALL CALL US WHEN
IT'S COLD GOES WRONG -- BUT
HOPEFULLY WE WILL HAVE WE WILL
SEE THAT ENGAGEMENT OF THE
VARIOUS AGENCIES AND A
COMMITMENT THAT'S THERE.
AND OBVIOUSLY -- VISIT SOME OF
THE FACILITIES TO MAKE SURE
THINGS ARE DIFFERENT.
THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST
BUT THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
THERE IS THAT WE ALL WANT TO
HAPPEN.
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO HAPPEN BUT
WON'T HAVE HAPPENED RIGHT.
AND WE WANT TO GIVE THOSE OF YOU
WHO MAKING THE CHANGE THE
SUPPORT YOU NEED. TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
YOU KNOW AND SO I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT SO -- WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT IT EVEN IF WE
DON'T LOOK EXCITED BUT WE REALLY
ARE WERE DANCING INSIDE -- BUT
BUT WE DO WANT IT DONE RIGHT AND
I THINK THAT THE THE STAKES ARE
HIGH.
WITH REGARDS TO WHO IT'S GOING
TO IMPACT AND SO I JUST WANTED
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT THAT WE'VE
BEEN WAITING IT MOST OF US OF
LOOKING FOR SOMETHING AND WE
DIDN'T SEE A WHOLE LOT COME IN --
AND SO THAT WILL BE IMPORTANT
THAT WE THAT TO KEEP US IN THE
LOOP.
THAT WERE INVOLVED WHEN GAYS AND
THAT THE STAKEHOLDERS ALSO
INVOLVED IN ENGAGE BECAUSE
THEY'RE SKEPTICAL THAT THEIR
SUPPORT WILL BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
OR THE ENGAGEMENT WILL BE
PERMANENT OR ON GOING WITH THAT
BUT AND SO I DON'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN I WANT THEM TO KNOW THAT
THAT.
IS EQUALLY INVESTED IN THIS THIS
PROJECT AS WE ARE IN TERMS TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THIS ITEM WAS HELD
OPEN YOU ALSO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER.
NINE ALMOST AT THE END --
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE.
SEVEN EIGHT I THINK I'LL NUMBER
NINE DONNA.
YEAH MAYBE VISION BUREAU OF
GAMBLING ALL.
OKAY -- CARD ROOMS AND THIRD
PARTY PROVIDERS WORKLOAD
[inaudible]
WOW OKAY.
YOU GUYS LOOK PROSPEROUS.
THANK YOU MANAGER CHRIS RYAN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
THIS REQUEST IS FOR FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIRTY TWO
EXISTING POSITIONS.
THESE POSITIONS ARE CURRENTLY
SET TO EXPIRE AT THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR.
AND US DEFINITION MáS WHO IS
HERE TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
FEAR OF GAMBLING CONTROL
ACTIVITIES -- AT THIS POINT
WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
FINISH MáS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
BUREAU GALLON CONTROL -- JUST
BITE CAM BACKGROUND THE BEER
WORKS IN COOPERATION WITH THE
COMING TOGETHER CALIFORNIA GIMLI
CONTROL COMMISSION TO BASICALLY
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF GAMING
IN THE STATE -- BUT THE BUREAU
DOES -- ALL FOR ITS PART IS TO
CONDUCT SOME BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATIONS OF INDIVIDUALS
AND ENTITIES WHO ARE SEEKING
LICENSURE TO WORK IN A CARD ROOM
OR TO OWN A CAR DREW MORE THIRD
PARTY PROVIDERS -- BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE
BUREAU HAD RECEIVED WAS SOUGHT
AND RECEIVED TWELVE POSITIONS TO
HANDLE SOME OF THESE --
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION --
RULES -- THERE AFTER THE
LEGISLATURE -- PROVIDED US WITH
AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY POSITIONS
FOR WHICH WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL
AND THANKFUL -- FOR READY TIME
NOW THE WORD THE FUNDING IS GONE
FOR THOSE -- WHOLE THIRTY TWO
POSITIONS -- WHAT THAT MEANS TO
THE BUREAU IS THAT -- YOU WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE AN IMPACT OR
TO DECREASE THE KIND OF PENDING
CASES OF THEIR IN HOUSE BUT ALSO
TO KEEP UP WITH THE ONGOING WORK
LOAD.
WE'RE ON TRACK TO RECEIVE -- AN
ADDITIONAL ONE THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS -- MORE THAN WE
WERE FROM LAST YEAR SO IT'S VERY --
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE KEEP THOSE -- POSITIONS IN
HOUSE -- FAILURE TO DO SO WOULD
REALLY IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO
DELIVER ULTIMATELY SUPPOSED TO
DO WHICH IS TO KEEP OUT A EIGHT
DISHONEST CORRUPT CRIMINAL
ELEMENT OUT OF THE GAMBLING
ESTABLISHMENTS.
THE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE SHARE
AND WHICH I WERE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WOULD JUST SAY THAT --
LIMITED TERM FUNDING FOR THE
BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL IS --
KIND OF DIFFICULT -- HE'S
POSITIONS IT TAKES AWHILE TO ON
BOARD THEM TO HIRE THEM ANYTIME
YOU HAVE LIMITED TIME TERM
FUNDING -- THERE'S ALWAYS A
CHANCE PEOPLE ARE GONNA FIND
ANOTHER JOB AND IT TAKES IT
TAKES AWHILE FOR THEM SO THAT'S
WHY THIS PROPOSAL IS ONGOING --
FUNDING THERE'S ALSO PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE HAS PROPOSED THAT
ALLOWS FINANCE -- UPON APPROVAL
BY THE JAIL BC TO AUGMENT OR
REDUCE THE BUDGET AS NEEDED
BASED ON WORKLOAD NEEDS AS WELL.
COMING FROM LA OKAY I NEED ONLY
WHAT THEY ALEJO -- WE ARE
RECOMMENDING -- PROVIDING ONE
TIME FUNDING TO JUST RETAIN THE
POSITIONS AND PART OF THE
RATIONALE FOR THAT IS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR IS AND
TOWARDS THE END OF COMPLETING AN
AUDIT.
OF THE REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES
FROM THE GAME THE CONTROL FUND
WHICH SUPPORTS THIS WORKLOAD AND
PART OF THE SCOPE INCLUDE SOME
THINGS THAT ARE CORE TO KIND OF
AN OUT ANALYZING THE WORKLOAD SO
FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY ARE REVIEWING -- THE
OVERALL PROCESS IN TERMS OF HOW
EFFICIENT THE PROCESSES WHETHER
THE STATUTORY TIME FRAMES ARE
BEING THAT AS WELL AS WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS A BACKLOG AND WHAT
ARE THE CAUSES OF THAT BACKLOG.
AND SO PROVIDING -- FUNDING ON A
LIMITED HER BASIS WOULD ALLOW
BOTH THE BUREAU AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND KIND OF
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE LONG TERM
IPACT.
OF THOSE COULD BE SO FOR EXAMPLE
IT COULD INVOLVE CHANGES TO THE
OVERALL PROCESS ARE KIND OF IT
IN TERMS OF LIKE WHAT'S DONE THE
TIME FRAME EXCITER AND SO THAT
COULD HAVE RAMIFICATIONS ON ON
GOING NEED FOR FUNDING AND STUFF.
RIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
BECOMES FOR MEMBERS.
IS THE ONE FROM THE AUDIENCE.
JUST VERY QUICKLY THIS OF THE
AUDIT WILL BE RELEASED TOMORROW
MORNING ACTUALLY SO THAT.
WE CAN GET AN IDEA THAN WE CAN
SPEAK TO IT BECAUSE IT'S
CONFIDENTIAL BUT CERTAINLY THERE
ARE THINGS THAT IT WAS FOR THE
THE REJECTED THE BUREAU'S
LOOKING AT CERTAINLY TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT -- WE
BELIEVE THAT I MEAN NOT JUST
THESE THREE TWO POSITIONS BUT
POTENTIALLY WE WOULD NEED MORE
POSITIONS JUST TO HANDLE 
CURRENT ONGOING WORKLOAD THE
KIND OF THE ANNUAL WORKLOAD THAT
WE GET -- SO -- WE DO THINK THE
PERMANENT FUNDING ALSO WAS
FINANCE SAID HAVING THE HAVING
THE DIFFICULTIES WITH THE HIRING --
WE ARE IN THE VISION LAW
ENFORCEMENT IT IS AN EXTENDED
HIRING PROCESS.
AND THEN IT'S USUALLY LIKE A SIX
MONTH PROCESS JUST TO GET
SOMEONE.
UP -- SIX MONTHS FOR THE HARRY
BUT SIX MONTHS ALSO JUST TO GET
THEM -- UP TO SPEED TO BE ABLE
TO HANDLE THE WORKLOAD SO HAVING
PEOPLE BE WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
POSITIONS AND LEAVING IT TAKES A
LONG TIME TO GET US BACK UP TO
SPEED AGAIN SO.
THAT'S ALSO CONSENT -- IT'S
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU HAVE A
TEMPORARY HIRING ARE YOU YOUR
MONEY FUNNY AND SO AS A RESULT
IT'S HARD TO GET PEOPLE TO THE
STATE WE'VE HAD THAT WITH OTHER
AGENCIES AS WELL.
YEAH.
PRESENTING PARK WEST CASINOS BUT
ALSO SPEAKING IF YOU WILL WAS A
AS A FORMER CHIEF DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL FROM
PREHISTORIC TIMES WHO USED.
TO MANAGE THIS -- WHEN IT WAS A
DIVISION AS WELL AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT HAVING SUCH A?
SIGNIFICANT FRACTION OF A
RELATIVELY SMALL WORKFORCE BEING
LIMITED TERM FOR AS LONG AS
THESE FOLKS HAVE BEEN -- IS
REALLY A BIG BURDEN ON THE REST
OF MANAGEMENT AND GETTING THE
JOB DONE I I DON'T I THINK I
WOULD SPEAK FOR ANYONE IN THE
INDUSTRY THIS IS ONE THING THEY
WOULD AGREE ON IS THEY WANNA.
PROFESSIONAL COMPETENT
EXPERIENCED.
STAFF THAT'S BEEN THERE LONG
ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND THE
INDUSTRY.
SO WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THANK MAKING THEM PERMANENT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE OKAY OKAY.
THANK YOU THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD
OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT THE
FINAL ITEM OF THE DAY WHICH IS
ITEM NUMBER.
TEN WHICH IS CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE UTILIZATION REVIEW AND
EVALUATION SYSTEM CURES PROGRAM
YES GREAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CHRIS RYAN DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
THIS IS A PROPOSAL TO IMPLEMENT --
FOR BILLS THAT WERE PASSED IN
THE LAST SESSION -- I HAVE SOME
PROGRAM STAFF HERE TO GIVE AN
OVERVIEW.
I GENERALLY SPEAKING -- CURES
WAS CREATED IN -- NINETEEN
NINETY SIX IT'S PROCESSED OVER
FIFTY MILLION -- PRESCRIPTION
RECORDS -- IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THERE WERE SOME
MANDATES -- THAT WERE PUT INTO
PLACE AND AND THAT IS GONNA
CHANGE THE THE FOR THE FRAMEWORK
OF THE SYSTEM AND THERE WERE
SOME BILLS THAT WENT THROUGH
LAST YEAR.
THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION AND REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY -- TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES IT'S A PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS SOUNDS GOOD.
ANY COMMENT FROM FINANCE IN THE
COMING FROM LA -- I DIDN'T THINK
SO OKAY ANY COME INTO MEMBERS.
ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE WANT TO
SAY A MAN OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT AS WELL AS
TOMORROW DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS WITH THIS ITEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
NOT THAT ITEM TO WILL BE HELD
OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA BUT
TAKES US BACK TO VOTING WE HAVE
A COUPLE BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL --
I THINK THE VOTE ON SOME OF THEM
IS.
TO TO TO AND SO WE'RE GONNA DO
THOSE BILLS FIRST AND THEN WE'LL
DO ALL THE OTHER ADD ONS.
THE ONES THAT ARE ON CALL --
INCREASE PEACE OFFICER TRAINING
ITEM ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE VOTE
IS RIGHT NOW TO THE TO WITH THE
WEBER AND STONE VOTING TO BUY
AND THE OTHERS NOT VOTING AT ALL.
A CALL THE ROLL JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
OUR HI.
THAT'S A THREE TWO VOTE THAT
ITEM PASSES -- THE OTHER ITEM IS
OF ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
APPROVALS BUDGET IT ADOPTED PLAY
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR THE
PENAL CODE REVIEW.
RIGHT NOW IT'S I'D HAVE AYE AYES
HAVE -- TO KNOWS HAVE TO SO A
ROLL CALL WAS -- TO TO JONES
SAWYER BY.
THAT MAKES IT OUT ON THREE TWO
TO VOTE OKAY ITEM NUMBER ISSUE
NUMBER.
FOUR IS AN OUT -- WE HAVE ISSUE
NUMBER TEN CANNABIS CONVICTION
RE SENTENCING -- TO TO TO VOTE
WAS TWO ONE TWO WE HAVE WEBER
AND STONE VOTING I'D -- LACKEY
NOT VOTING AND OBERNOLTE VOTING
NO.
CALL THE ROLL JONES SAWYER.
GUY.
OKAY THAT IS THREE TWO ONE WITH
ONE ABSTENTION IN THAT BILL IS
OUT.
OKAY WE NOW HAVE ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN WHICH IS THE INCREASE
IN INMATE LITERACY THE VOTE NOW
IS TO PUT -- IT WITH WEBER AND
STONE VOTING I'D NOT VOTING IS
LACKEY AND NO VOTING IS
OBERNOLTE.
WE'LL CALL JONES SAWYER HI.
THAT IS OUT WITH THREE TWO ONE
AND ONE OF SENTIENT.
OKAY THOSE THOSE OF THOSE ALL
THOSE BILLS ALL OF OUR BILLS ARE
OUT WOULD NOW GO BACK TO GET THE
ADD ON MISTER.
JONES SAWYER WROTE.
WE'VE OF CALL THE THE NUMBERS
THAT HE NEEDS TO ADD ON TO OKAY.
YES PLEASE READ EACH ONE THAT HE
HAS NOT VOTED ON YEAH VOTE ONLY
ISSUE TO MAY REVISION AMENDMENT
TO TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
APPROVE ITS BUDGET.
THE ITEM IS OUT NOW ON A FIVE OH
VOTE.
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL VOTE
ON THE ISSUE THREE ONLINE
OVERSIGHT.
THAT I ADAMS A FIVE OH VOTE.
BUT ON THE ISSUE FIVE JUVENILE
COURT PROBATION STATISTICAL
SYSTEM.
THAT VOTE IS OUT ON A FIVE OH
VOTE.
VOTE ON THE ISSUE SIX PEACE
OFFICER RADIO REPLACEMENT
APPROVE IS BUDGETED HI.
THE ITEMS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE.
BUT ONLY ISSUE SEVEN CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN APPROVE IS BUDGETED HI.
THAT I DON'T IS OUT ON A FIVE OH
VOTE.
NOT ONLY ISSUE A CALIFORNIA
INTERNET CONSUMER PROTECTION NET
NEUTRALITY ACT APPROVED PROPOSAL
IT UP BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
SPECIFYING THAT BINDING CAN ONLY
BE SPENT. FOR COURT PROVISIONS
PREVENTING IMPLEMENTATION OR
ENFORCEMENT HAVE EXPIRED BEEN
REMOVED.
BILL IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
VOTE ON THE ISSUE NINE OF PEACE
OFFICERS VIDEO AUDIO RECORDING
AND TECHNICAL FIX APPROVED
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND ONE
POSITION TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND ONGOING AN ADULT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE HI.
AND ITEMS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE.
VOTE ON THE ISSUE ELEVEN VARIOUS
PROPOSALS TO IMPLEMENT
LEGISLATION JONES SAWYER HI.
THAT THE ITEM WAS OUT ON A FIVE
ZERO VOTE.
BUT ONLY ISSUE TWELVE NEW AND
EXPANDED CRIMES.
THAT VOTE IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE.
UP VOTE ONLY ISSUE THIRTEEN
DISPOSITIONS WORKLOAD REJECT
PROPOSAL.
HI.
IT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
OF OUR ONLY ISSUE FOURTEEN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SEXUAL PREDATORY
APPREHENSION TEAMS APPROVALS
BUDGETED.
THAT ITEM WAS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE VOTE ONLY ISSUE FIFTEEN OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY NEW INYO
JUVENILE FACILITY FAMILY
COURTHOUSE IMPERIAL COUNTY NEW
EL CENTRO COURTHOUSE.
APPROVE IS BUDGETED HI.
BUT I'D OF A THOUGHT ON FIVE
ZERO VOTE ON THESE ISSUES
SIXTEEN MAY REVISION TRIAL COURT
FIND EMPLOYEE BENEFITS
ADJUSTMENT HARDCORE TRIBES
TRESTMAN SHORTFALL ADJUSTMENT.
APPROVE ITS BUDGET BY THAT ITEMS
ON ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
BUT ONLY ISSUE SEVENTEEN
CORRECTIONAL TRAINING FACILITY
SOLID AT AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION -- SOLD OR RETROFIT.
PROPOSAL.
AS I READ YOUR AD WAS OUT ON A
FIVE ZERO THE ONLY ISSUE
EIGHTEEN DOOR VOCATIONAL
INSTITUTION NEW BOILER FACILITY
REJECT PROPOSAL.
HI THAT ITEM WAS OUT ON A FIVE
ZERO A VOTE ON THE ISSUE TWENTY
VARIOUS HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS WAS
BUDGETED BY.
THAT ITEM IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE VOTE ONLY SHE TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD FOR MEN AIR
COOLING FACILITY A PREVIOUS
BUDGETED HI.
THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
BUT ONLY ISSUE TWENTY TWO HEALTH
CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM INCREASED LEASE REVENUE
APPROPRIATION OF HIS BUDGET A
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BY.
THE ROAD THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE
ZERO VOTE VOTE ONLY ISSUE --
TWENTY THREE SPRING B. C. P.
STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS APPROVE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION BY.
IT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
BUT ONLY ISSUE TWENTY FOUR
SPRING BCP'S HANK QUENTIN STATE
PRISON NEW BOILER FACILITY
APPRISED BUDGETED THAT IS OUT ON
A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
THE ONLY ISSUE TWENTY FIVE PRO
HEARING COMMISSIONERS TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE APPROVE THE
PROPOSAL ABOUT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
AND IT'S ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
BUT ONLY ISSUE TWENTY SIX
VARIOUS MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
ADOPT STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS.
IT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
VOTE ON THE ISSUE -- TWENTY
SEVEN OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES EXTENSION OF
LIQUIDATION OF PROPOSITION ONE
BE APPROVED AS BUDGET BY.
THOSE OUT ANY FIVE ZERO VOTE.
THE ONLY ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT
VARIOUS MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
APPROVE IS BUDGETED HI THAT IS
OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE JUDGES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM BUT ONLY ISSUE
TWENTY NINE VARIOUS MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS APPROVALS BUDGETED BY.
THAT IT'S ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE.
THAT INCLUDES ALL THAT CONCLUDES
AT ALL ALL OF THE ITEMS ARE OUT
WHO WERE UP FOR VOTE TODAY.
I HAVE PASSED IN OUR INNER OUT
ANY -- ANY ADDITIONS OR
CORRECTIONS IN A INFORMATION A
QUESTIONS GUESS NOT THAT SOLD IN
THE MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH